good uh good morning everyone it is
9:45 and my mother is watching and she
likes when I'm on
time so if I could grab everyone's
attention and then uh we're going to
stand representative alalani is going to
lead us in the Pledge of
Allegiance
Ali to the flag United States of America
and to the repblic for stands one na God
you I'd like to thank everyone um for
your professionalism in the last two
weeks when I was gone I did uh watch one
live and I have watched the other on
YouTube and and
uh um as I said uh representative D
sylvestro thank you uh when when uh Vice
chairman seaworth asked for someone to
introduce the bill that the sponsor had
wanted it I was kind of counting 1 1000
2 1000 3 1000 who was going to stand up
so thank you very much representative D
sylvestro um our goal folks here is to
um come close to finishing up our
hearing
today we will be meeting not next week
but the week after to finish up on the
right to work uh Bill the people that
still would like to speak and to have
some exact
sessions um tentatively I believe it's
Wednesday the 7th and then we'll be
8th those are the early bills we'll be
dealing with it we still have another
week and I don't like
to push things to the last minute where
if we have an early bill that we're
really close on and you know it you
can't just like sit here for two hours
and wait for OS to make an amendment to
bring it back so that that's why I'm
doing it a week
ahead um it'll give us extra time if on
those six early bills so I will get that
out and emailed everybody just got a at
lunchtime I'll find out from our um
assistant have to make sure the room's
available which I'm pretty sure it is uh
representative seaworth had a two-hour
delay with his children he'll be in
representative Drago had a sick child
but still appreciate you you know
plowing sanding and sick child and you
got here this morning so thank you very
much any other questions of the chair
before we open the
hearing uh I am going to call a a a
subcommittee on one of the bills uh
Brian seaworth Bill about the um
increase from $300 to $3,000 for a pay
in the event of a death uh
representative U Sullivan and I will
grab talk to some people and announce
who that subcommittee is going to
break anything else before we
begin okay as I told my friends over
here I have two gavels and I can't
remember to bring any of them so opening
the hearing on House Bill 1522 and I
McKenzie my name is
mesent
HRI is your mic on thank you it is
now thank you for all reminding
me so this bill
um deals with an issue of increasing the
unemployment benefits the they have not
been adjusted since two 2007 in fact
representative infant time was part of
the bill that adjust them the last time
they were done um so this expands takes
the existing structure and expands uh it
as it appears in the current law taking
the existing schedule I adjusted the
table by applying the Consumer Price
Index from the time of the last
adjustment which is 2007 up until
2017 in addition this bill creates an
additional 19 steps to expand the
schedule to accommodate the higher wage
earners who lose out as a current
schedule uh uh schedule stops at 415
with a maximum Benefit of
$427 Mr chairman I I neglected to pass
out this little uh handout so feel free
um you want to pass one on down on
either side and
uh leave one um if there's an empty seat
folks just leave one and pass the rest
down if you wouldn't
mind the new schedule uh will bring the
top rate up to
$57,500 uh which is a maximum benefit of
$753 uh
$57,500 is approximately the amount
needed to meet individual consumption
costs such as rent medical
transportation of food this amount Falls
far short of the average weekly wage in
New Hampshire which is around $1,400 a
week or
7200 uh
72,800 the current replacement rate at
the bottom of the schedule was around
60% of the average weekly wage and the
rate deteriorates from from that to
about 28 to
32% uh because the fact that the current
dollar amount for the top end of the
schedule is $41,500
so anything over and above that if
you're making more than that uh that's
where you top out at and there's going
to be evidence presented uh by the
department to show that there are number
of people who actually hit that
threshold
[Music]
um to help uh better understand I I
don't know how many people are familiar
with the way that the UI system actually
works um so I wanted to give just a
couple of minutes orientation about uh
how I see the system works uh how the
money gets into the system and uh what
the various taxes that employers pay in
the state of New Hampshire those of you
who are employers uh understand fter and
sudor and bunch of other taxes that uh
that you have to pay so let me say this
that the initial uh this law was
initially passed as part of the the
Social Security Act it was Roosevelt's
initiative to provide for safety nets
that under which people uh was put under
people so they would not fall into into
poverty so we went online back in the
30s I think it was 30 36 37 maybe
earlier than that with the UI system uh
in the state of New Hampshire and I
actually have uh the initial all of the
initial uh the initial law and all of
the updates from the time the law was
initially
passed so the money that comes into the
uh the unemployment fund uh says uh it
goes into a it goes into a federal fund
called the trust fund the trust fund
then uh draws down the state draws down
from the trust fund uh for the purpose
of paying benefits and it can only be
used uh to pay unemployment
benefits uh and the what the law also
says is that uh the states cannot impose
excessively burdensome methods of
administration that would block access
for otherwise eligible
individuals these requirements sure that
the states maintain a program that
offers a basic level of protection to
workers with sufficient uh employment
Records who lose their job through no
fault of their own and Within These
basic protection states are free to
choose and adjust the employer tax rate
benefit levels and durations and that is
an important thing to to understand is
that this system uh and there many
people who think this is the wrong way
to do it but the states under the this
current system have the authority all
throughout the country so every state
has a different set of benefits every
state uh does things differently as
opposed to the uh in comparison to the
Social Security system which is a
national system and and National
benefits but that was the way it came
out the the system itself accumulates
money through two sources one is the
Fooda tax uh which is a Federal
Unemployment uh tax um and uh and that
is based on uh the tax rate is 6% on the
first
$7,000 and so the maximum uh how you can
qualify for benefits a lower that rate
um but for the most part uh you can go
as low as 6% but the but the max you pay
is $420 for the food attx and it comes
down as depending on on various factors
um
the pseud tax on the other hand is
variable and set by the states so the
state sets individual
rates uh and the way that's done in a
nutshell is that uh there is a tax a
suit tax begins at 2. 7
2.7% and then is adjusted based on uh
the experience of the of the of the
employer higher number of people laid
off the more expensive it is uh
depending on what industry you're in if
you're in construction as opposed to
office work if it's a more stable
environment you tend to have a lower uh
a lower rate now that's a real quick
pass at at how that works but every year
they take a look and they look back and
they say what was the experience of the
of the employer then they assign a rate
um they assign a rate to the employer
and that's what they pay now beginning
is 2.7 it can go up uh um and if you tip
over there are two actually there's a
divide there those who are positive
rated employees and those are negative
rated employees the negative rated
employees take more out of the system
than they put in and therefore they the
rate tends to be
higher
um the the amount that you pay
on uh is based on
$114,000 that's the top end of the tax
so you can't ex you don't exceed that uh
so so depending on what your rate is you
apply that to the 14,000 and that's how
you make a determination as to what the
amount of money would
be
uh so all of this money that's collected
ends up in what's known as the trust
fund and uh the trust fund
has a series of
applied and this is an important this is
an important thing
because the trust fund uh has the uh
depending on what the level of the of
the dollar amount is or the trust fund
at anyone particular time you they apply
a a half
perc uh and the schedule uh equals or
exceeds 250 million uh if it goes above
uh 350 million there's another discount
they go above 400 uh million there's
another discount and they are very close
right now uh to getting to that point
where the trust fund will have some $400
million in
it you can pay uh if you to think the
lowest you can pay in the state is um
from what I remember is
0.1% uh because depending on what your
rate is how you're rated and then you
apply these discounts it's low
again um there's two things in play here
there's the there's a the amount of
money that can be collected which are
tax taxable wages and uh that goes into
the trust fund
now over the time what they have done is
to
um is to change that 14,000 I think it
was 10,000 they maybe gone to 12 the
last time they went up to
14,000 and uh for the average employer
in New Hampshire at least from what I
could see in 2002 it was about New
Hampshire ended up with about
$359 uh per employee but I think you're
going to hear that that's actually much
less uh than uh the employees are
currently
paying
now what
um what happens is that and you could
see on on page six I think of the
handout on the what's known as trust
fund
solvency um this is getting a little in
the weeds and probably wouldn't do this
for other committees but those of us
who're going to deal with this these
issues of unemployment I think it's
important to understand so trust fund
solvency is a is a is a uh a number that
a target number that they're looking at
so the federal government says uh one is
the is the target number uh that takes
into consideration it's a bunch of
different factors but the trust fund
solvency is a way to look and compare
one state to another looks at at at
where you are in terms of your your
solvency um New Hampshire is is uh the
last look at this thing in 2023 they
were uh uh 0. n uh and they want to be
at one and I think they I think they're
already there I'm not you know better
from these guys uh but I think they're
almost actually there on page seven you
can see the top of page seven you can
see what the um what the what it would
look like if you were to take a look at
at the report that's uh the federal
government has that that looks at trust
fund solvency issues and that's an
important number because it gives you a
sense as a as a uh without digging too
deep as to where this fund overall the
fund
is now the cost of the benefits the
benefits for the unemployed workers have
not been raised by the legislation more
than 17 years years and even when it was
raised back 17 years ago it only
Incorporated the top it added some
additional steps to the top three or
four steps to the
top the current uh system has uh no
automatic mechanism for increasing
benefits and this is I think where the
rubber hits the road in terms of the
policy piece because every time uh you
want an increase in the in the um in the
benefit then you need to come in and to
the legisl file legislation as we're
doing here to increase that that
benefit and traditionally what happens
is because employers this is an employer
funded
uh uh program the employeers naturally
react to that because as you raise the
benefits it's going to become more
expensive uh for employers the question
I think from a policy perspective is at
what point um what what is what is the
number that we need to get to from the
from the perspective of what's fair and
what's Equitable and what meets the
mission of the organization and I asked
that question the other day in front of
the advisory committee and I pretty much
knew the answer there is no number there
is no recommendation from uh at least
from the uh from the
system uh as to what that number should
be
so what's happened in New Hampshire is
that the number the the benefit has
continued to slide and decline uh with
time which is where we're at right now
now you the problem with where we are
and we do we've seen this in other
pieces of legislation is it has fallen
behind and it gets increasingly more
expensive to catch up even if you would
to just catch up by using the CPI the
current system it gets more expensive
expensive to catch up so that if the
system is in place and the
responsibility of the system and the
goal of the system is provide
replacement wages at time when people
through no fault of their own are
unemployed we have to we have to take
into
consideration how adequate the current
benefit is and where we think that needs
to be from a policy perspective and
clearly that's our job it's not the
Department's job they've made that uh
pretty
clear but if you look at the um in 1977
what they did is the uh is they they put
in this is in the Preamble of the the
state law uh and I was surprised to see
it but it's there and here's what it
here's basically what the legislature in
1977 said it says now therefore the
general court declares the public good
and the general welfare of workers in
the state requir the enactment of
workers compensation laws providing for
setting aside of unemployed reserves to
be used for the benefit purpose of
unemployed through uh through no fault
of their own and for providing a
systematic accumulation of funds so the
legislates uh you know says that it's
that providing these benefits is
important that's what they decided that
was the thing that they that they uh put
into the law and it's currently in
the the um currently in the book
now here's here's the thing about
unemployment from my experience it
serves two real purposes uh in the state
the first thing is to provide support
for unemployed workers when they are
laid off to no fault of their own and it
also stabilizes the economy in the state
of New Hampshire now I worked on the uh
the shutdown of the plant the paper
plant in Berlin New Hampshire and if you
wanted to see what happens when a
shutdown occurs now that's a very unique
situation it was a one hos town and when
that shut down it destroyed the economy
in the in the state of New Hampshire in
in that part of the state but for the
unemployment
system those workers would have have
nothing and getting them back to work
was even a bigger issue and we spent a
long time and a lot of money uh trying
to get those those workers stabilized so
so unemployment in that case that
example shows that it has a role of
stabilizing communities and a role of
providing benefits for work workers but
the other thing that it does is it keeps
intact the workforce that we currently
have in New Hampshire if there were no
unemployment system there's a good
possibility workers would leave the
state to look for other work they'd be
forced to so if you want as an employer
to maintain a Workforce in the state and
keep them during times of economic uh
Cycles then unemployment helps to to
serve that
purpose
now on page um on page nine at the top
schedule and what this shows is that the
the top of the SC I'm sorry that it's a
little it's not going to be as pretty as
the department ofemployment security
stuff that's coming up
shortly um but what that shows is this
is going to be about the cost issue so
the top of the scale on the right right
hand side refers to the wages that are U
being generated in the state of New
Hampshire it's called the total taxable
wages and you can see that that had that
number has gone up considerably over the
course of the
years the bottom is the percent of total
wages that are taxable under the current
system and you can see the
relationship the tax of the wages are
going up the amount of wages are going
up but the relationship uh is is
declining so there's less and less uh as
I see understand that there were less
wages uh percent of total wages that are
being taxed in the state so there is
some room there when we look at at uh
how we designed this bill there is some
room
there let me
um the the other thing there were a
number of bills in the in the department
uh in in play here not the in the
department but in play I think the
Senate's got two or three of them we may
have a couple here as
well and I think what need we need to
take a look at is the next uh is maybe
spend a little bit of time digging into
the unemployment system and taking a
look at at some of the things and then
trying to come together now what I
proposed uh in 1522 is to raise the
scale and when you begin to look at
you'll hear you'll hear some of this um
the replacement value is on my bill is
in the 70 some odd percent range
currently it's uh around 50 depends on
where you are in the scale but it's in
the 50 or 60% range for the lower end of
the
scale you what's the ideal number I
think probably as as I look at at and
talk to the me from the Department I
think the numbers that I propose are too
high and I'm wide open to amending that
but I think we have to uh make sure that
we protect the higher wage uh earners in
the state which are losing out uh and
there's some evidence to show how many
of them are and this uh this legislation
attempts to do that let me just say and
finish up
here but there were a couple of other
indicators uh in in the system that I
think we need to probably take a look
at uh and I don't have I don't have a
strong opinion about this yet because I
just don't know enough about it but the
national numbers um and refer to what's
known as the recipiency rate and the
recipiency rate is a number of people
who are collecting benefits who are
eligible to collect in relation to who
is eligible to collect them and that
number is fairly
low uh we are behind the curve in terms
of the federal government in 19 uh 200
22 we were at 11% and the federal rate
was
25% uh in 2023 was 177% the federal rate
29% so the question I have are people
just not filing for the benefits that
they're
entitled uh secondly um I I think that
we we might want to look at uh the work
requirements and to see if in fact the
work
requirements um are discouraging people
from filing for
unemployment because it's tough to file
for unemployment and um and and to do
what you need to do when you find for
unemployment you got to be looking for
work all the time now there are there
are ways that you you know there are
some Provisions in there the
commissioner can look at the jobs but
for the most part you got to be actively
available and seeking work now I if
you're in Berlin New Hampshire there's
about 850 employees in Berlin New
Hampshire if you're in the southern part
of the state and you're knocking outoors
there's thousands of employers in the in
the southern part of the state so this
doesn't uh vary as best as I can
determine it's the same requirements are
the same so how many times can you knock
on somebody's door in Berlin New
Hampshire looking for work um but that's
that's and again um the Department's
here you can you can ask them but the
other thing that really is a little
disturbing to me uh is this particular
poster that appears in the uh
unemployment compensation quick
tips and what this rep what this is is
the picture of a person behind
bars welcome to the employment security
system now there are people commit fraud
and that's a serious concern and the
department has a robust system of
enforcing the
law but putting something like this into
uh an intro packet and may not be there
anymore um is a little discouraging
would scare the heck out of me uh first
of all you got to go through the whole
system and if you make a mistake then
potentially is this in net result that
this could happen you know that may be
an exaggeration but clearly people there
are people who who take advantage of the
system and they can go to jail for
that so I you know I think uh it's our
job now clearly our job to figure this
thing out it's not not another
committee's job it's our job right now I
think that we have enough information
and we going to get more information
from the Department about about this um
but it's time I think after 17 years to
do something to do something that
increases a benefit for workers and
protects uh the workers in the state of
New Hampshire in cases of economic
downturn 50,000 people nearly 50,000
people every day leave the state of New
Hampshire to go to Massachusetts
it's a drain a brain drain in New
Hampshire and these are not low-wage
workers these are high-tech uh workers
who are leaving the state you're going
to hear from one of the uh speakers from
the building trads uh and you make a
comparison between what the difference
is in a building transect from going to
Massachusetts and getting unemployed and
working in New Hampshire and getting
unemployed is a very different situation
believe so uh I'll end with that we you
know the subcommittee we can certainly
deal with this again there were number
of bills in front of the Senate that we
may end up all getting together
on thank you Mr chairman I'm sorry that
took so long lot of information no
worries no worries that we have plenty
of time for this hearing I knew would be
a lot of discussion so no worries uh
representative Schultz thank you Mr
chair um is there a consideration or an
interest on your part to include
um I'm not exactly sure how to put this
getting rid of the sort of penalty that
some some folks incur when they're
unemployed that if they get short-term
gigs and if it falls in the
redetermination period it actually can
mean a reduction in the unemployment
rate when it's essentially becomes a
penalty for um getting short-term gigs
do you know does that makes do am I
explaining that well enough I think that
um you know looking at at things like
this looking at the whole work
requirement piece um it's going to take
time to go through that uh but but I and
I but I think we should do it at some
point to see what barriers are there
what happens to people for instance uh
the
department in I think it was March of
last year um put out a press release
that they had
overpaid uh thousands of people and it
was in the 90 some odd million dollar
range that they had overpaid
people I don't know how that happened uh
I'm sure they'll have an explanation for
that but that what that meant is that
thousands of people were overpaid and
somebody had to claw that money back
from people uh now did these people do
this on purpose did they you know I
would doubt it I think they could have
made a mistake they could have you know
misread the um misread the thing but the
fact is that there were a whole lot of
people people that were paid benefits
they didn't belong and now they the
responsibility to bring it back um I
think th those are one of number
examples representative Schultz U the
next bill
yeahor repres Sullivan's Bill 1597 is is
coming up to deal with that fantastic
thank you any other questions for
McKenzie thank you Mr chair and thanks
for taking my question would this
legislation be necessary if New
Hampshire used sound money that didn't
inflate away over
time I don't know that was the question
would this go fade away if the state
used found
money uh would this legislation be
necessary if New Hampshire used sound
money that didn't inflate away to
okay I I have no I I don't know what to
say I don't know I was absent that day
in finance
class I understand your question I
understand where you're coming from from
me just have a good
response thank you for the question any
other questions for represent
McKenzie seeing done thank you very much
thank you we have two individuals here
from the um Department of Employment
Securities are you gentlemen going to be
testifying
together Rich lavers from the uh labors
from the uh new Employment
Securities
yourselves good morning everybody Rich
LA's Deputy Commissioner with the N
Hampshire Department of Employment
Security Brian golob director of the
economic and labor market information
Bureau of the Department of Employment
Security um so we had uh provided some
material I think it was as
representative McKenzie had referred to
is the pretty packet um that folks had
received so it's um some information
that we feel is is relevant to the
matter at hand and the consideration of
uh whether or not benefits should be
increased so we have a quite a bit of
information in there um but just before
we start going through that there were a
number of points um that representative
McKenzie had raised um that aren't
addressed in here that I felt important
to quickly discuss and I think some of
them um he actually invited me to
discuss um with bringing up the topics
um regarding overpayments
um so we've we had a significant amount
of overpayments to the tune of over $100
million during the pandemic almost all
of that was Federal and almost all of it
was because the federal government kept
on changing the rules for people that
were filing during the pandemic and what
they did was they required states that
when those rules changed and someone
didn't meet the eligibility requirement
they needed to be found overpaid
however in most instances those
individuals would not be required to pay
those benefits back they'd be what the
federal government refers to as waved
benefits so we actually created a
process on our website where individuals
who were in that circumstance could go
right on the website I think it was four
clicks answer a few questions required
by the federal government and those
Federal overpayments would be forgiven
with nothing repaid by them no impact on
the state's trust fund cuz they were
Federal benefits but for the most part
those were all federal benefits
individuals were not at fault and the
rules were changing um and the rules
were changing because the pandemic was
changing I mean let's go back in time
and remember how difficult that time
period was um the department made an
initial decision at the beginning of the
pandemic to get the money out the door
um because people needed it and in some
instances the rules changed resulting in
overpayments and the department did its
best to try to inform individuals um and
then help them get those overpayments
forgiven following a simplified version
of the federal rules so just to kind of
uh put that into context the most common
reason for overpayments of state
benefits is because of unreported
earnings so the picture that
representative McKenzie had shown that
is a page within the benefit rights
handbook that individuals are seeing
during the first 3 weeks of filing a
claim they come into the department and
they sit through what is usually about a
60-minute presentation of all the dos
and don'ts of filing for unemployment
how you when you need to file what the
weekly claim looks like what the
questions are asked what we need to be
uh what you need to be telling us with
regard to your work search efforts the
earnings that you have from part-time
employment during those weeks so we
provide all of that information but we
also spend spend a lot of time
explaining to people of unemployment
fraud and the importance of reporting
your earnings and we make sure they
understand the consequences of not
reporting your earnings because it has a
significant impact on the unemployment
trust fund and we actually have a
partnership with the New Hampshire
Attorney General's office where
individuals who commit egregious
unemployment fraud by not reporting
earnings from not just $100 here $100
there I'm talking full time employment
earnings not being not being reported to
the department despite very clear and
simple
questions over the course of sometimes
10 20 30 weeks not
reported why well it's certainly not
because of the department not informing
them of their obligations to report
those earnings and when those situations
are egregious we prosecute them through
our partnership with theor Attorney
General's office which has been in place
since about 2015 and I think it's
important that we do so because those
benefits need to be available for
individuals that are unemployed through
no fault of their own and they are
looking for employment not those
individuals that might have had a
qualifying separation but then find new
employment and decide that it's in their
best interest to continue to receive
their full unemployment benefit and not
report their new full-time employment
earnings so unemployment fraud is real
it's something we take very seriously as
you can see from the picture in the the
benefit rights book which I make no
apologies for including that I think
it's important that we are very straight
with individuals when they come in so
that they understand what the what the
um penalties are that can result if they
fail to report their earnings while
collecting unemployment benefits um with
regard to
solvency um representative McKenzie had
had talked about trust fund solvency
it's a it's a great topic I think
there's a handful of us in the state
that um um spend time dealing with it um
the federal government rates every state
okay they they come out every year
usually in March they come out with
their Federal um trust fund solvency
report and I think um what it looked
like representative McKenzie had shown
was each state has a page um and they
update that annually usually in March
although I think last year they might
have um come out a little bit earlier in
February so there'll be a new report
coming out very soon um it'll have what
they call an average high cost
multiplier an ahcm um for each state and
as representative McKenzie had indicated
the goal for each state is to have an
ahcm of
1.0 that is the federal government uh
indicating that they feel that that
State's trust fund is solvent the way
they do that they look at total wages
they look at total employment and they
also look at your at your three biggest
benefit payout years during the last 20
and that's how they rate to see whether
or not your state can
withstand an unknown storm coming with
the next economic downturn so New
Hampshire when they last rated us we
were just over
0.9% um we have since seen a a continued
increase in the balance of our trust
fund we are up just below 400 million
right now we're about
396 in that range um I suspect that when
that new report comes out in the next
couple of months it will have New
Hampshire at that ahcm of 1.0 maybe a
little bit above um and that would put
us in probably with um less than two
dozen states that actually achieve that
Mark um so uh it's it's a point that New
Hampshire is proud of and we should um
it should uh uh be we should be mindful
that that means that whenever the next
downturn turn hits that New Hampshire
would be able to pay benefits to
unemployed individuals in New Hampshire
without having to rely upon the federal
government from taking action um and
from providing uh that back stop if we
were to run out run out of benefits so
it's it's an important indicator it's
the trust fund solvency measure is very
important um looking at the the
recipiency rate um I don't know how
useful recipiency rate is it is it it
has a lot of individuals in there who
didn't have enough earnings to qualify
for unemployment benefits um in New
Hampshire you have to have at least
$2,800 in earnings in your 4 quarter
based period in order to be monetarily
eligible uh some people don't have that
uncovered employment that influences
that recipiency rate number probably a
better measure is to look at our our uh
rates at which we deny and allow
benefits When individuals come in and
file um in New Hampshire's at about a
76% rate of allowing applications for
benefit benefits When individuals come
in right now that's probably a better
indicator of what the what the program
is doing um and then with regard to work
requirements yes um the federal
government requires each state to um
confirm that individuals are able for
able to work available to work and are
conducting an adequate work search to
demonstrate their attachment to the
labor market and you have to do that
each and every week because it is a
matter of continued eligibility
eligibility is determined from a week to
week basis so New Hampshire is required
by the federal government to ensure that
that that we're meeting able available
and labor force attachment now we do
that on your on an individual's weekly
claim they have a few screens on their
on their weekly claim that asks what
they did during the prior week for which
they are filing for unemployment
benefits um one of those things they can
do are contacting hiring employers we
encourage that early in your claim
though we understand there's a lot going
on in an individual's life after that
type of disruption so there's a lot of
activities that individuals are allowed
to participate in like uh utilizing some
of our re-employment resources like
upgrading your resume like upgrading
your list of contacts in your network um
so we have a lot of different activities
individuals can participate in and be
eligible for unemployment benefits
particularly in those first first few
weeks they can attend job fairs that the
department puts on they can come in and
utilize our job match system um either
at their home or in the department when
you get later on in your claim we really
focus on those employer contacts um
because there at that point um where if
you're exceeding average duration
something that you're doing is just not
robust enough and we really want to see
more employer contacts at that point in
time um I think there's a probably a lot
that we could do to strengthen that work
requ requirement um and I think right
now um with the activities that
individuals are are are able to
participate in uh to demonstrate their
efforts to seek new employment um I
think we try to strike a good balance of
what we need to do to make sure that
this partial temporary wage replacement
is as short as possible um because no
one wants to stay on unemployment longer
than they need to they want to get back
to work and we try to help them to do
that in the work requirement um the work
search requirement that they that they
fill out as part of their weekly
eligibility helps individuals do that um
so I'll um uh go back to what we were
planning on discussing but I can
certainly answer any questions with
regard to any of those topics if folks
those any questions about the previous
comments if I would ask you just to hold
for one moment um part of the
responsibility here of the uh labor
committee uh is for one of the members
to be part of the New Hampshire
unemployment Securities Advisory Board
representative Sullivan has done that
before I believe no you didn't when you
were chairman uh I uh I currently serve
in that
position we meet quarterly and we go
over all the details of what's going on
with unemployment Securities uh how the
trust funds doing how the expenses are
going how the computer systems working
all those things um and there's as a
senator and myself as rep there's a
number of M members of business and
members of Labor we did meet on Monday
uh it was our regular quarter quarterly
meeting uh I was there representative
mcken was also present um and we had
this presentation um you know I've been
doing this for 14 years understanding
all this and it's difficult so please if
if you're some of the things we're going
through understanding how the
unemployment Securities work it's not
very difficult but this is a lot of
stuff and there's a lot of words and
acronyms and things like that so at any
time you have a question just just this
presentation is going to take about 20
minutes of these these things here so
feel free to ask questions because it's
going to be very important to how you
make decisions of what we do with this
bill and a couple others so um I know
it's a lot it's going to be kind of a
learning experience for some of the
newer folks but um just want you to
understand um how the how the kind of
the system works behind the scenes and
what you're going to see today uh and
again representative McKenzie and I were
both in on the meeting we have seen this
presentation and um um I'll I'll let it
be there Mr C commissioner go ahead I
just wanted to let everyone know who
didn't know how how things kind of work
great now everyone knows we didn't put
this together specifically for them
correct
represent um if you have a question
that's prohibiting you from thinking
further on and what's going on you're
really confused I would like you to
interrupt I'll see your hand and I will
ask okay because chances are if you have
a question on some of this as it's going
through somebody else has the same
question all
right all right I'll get us started and
I I'll go um we'll you know just to
clarify we'll we'll start here um and um
go through these pages and and uh
director golob will jump in when we get
to some of the forecasting uh that we've
done to try to gauge the impact of
what's been proposed by representative
McKenzie so just to help level set for
everyone and and uh what we feel to
helpful to understand the impact of the
bill as proposed is to understand the
current system um so we just um provided
some basic information there U to
confirm some things you already heard
from representative McKenzie U with our
our current uh maximum weekly benefit
amount is
$427 a week uh that has been in place
since
2007 um currently that weekly benefit is
determined by how much a person earned
in their four quarter base period so
when you when you have a separation from
employment uh you come in and we look at
two things one we look to see that you
had enough earnings in covered
employment in W2 employment with a New
Hampshire employer uh you need to have
at least $2,800 in in earnings over that
four quarter period 1,400 of which need
to be and you need to have at least,
1400 in two separate quarters in order
to be what we refer to as monetarily
eligible um now you need to also have a
qualifying separation right you need to
have a separation from from employment
through no fault of your own so it's
both of those issues we then look at the
amount of of Base period earnings that
you had so the earnings that you had in
covered employment in your four quarters
to determine what your weekly benefit
amount is going to be so that maximum
amount of
$427 um requires that an individual had
at least
$41,500 in annual earnings in their base
period if you have more than that if you
have $80,000
in annual earnings your weekly benefit
amount is still $427 that's the maximum
amount available in New Hampshire um
when um and we go all the way down to as
I said to $2,800 that's the minimum
amount of earnings in your base period
to qualify for a weekly unemployment
benefit and all the way up to 415 at the
lower tiers at the lower tiers so at the
the lower earnings that wage replacement
rate or or how much um that unemployment
benefit replaces of what you were
earning when you were employed is in
that 60% range um when you get to the
higher tiers you're looking at more uh
along the lines of a lower lower 50%
wage replacement rate um and again um
the current benefit structure it was
last revised in 2006 it went into effect
in July of ' 07 and the the change that
was made at that time was to add five
additional tiers so um prior to that
change the maximum benefits went up to a
base period earning level of $36,500
that change in 2007 brought in a new
weekly benefit amount for 375 385
39545 uh and 41,500 at 427 so that was
the change that was done was to add
those five additional tiers okay um oh
I'm sorry I'm want to interrupt a couple
times does everyone understand rage
replacement
percentage what you way have been making
and what you're going to get as pay
payment for weekly um and the tiers
understand that it's based on how much
you make and there's different tiers and
you get more as you saw in
representative McKenzie's everyone got
that what is the lowest $8 uh $32
$32 so $32 is what the weekly benefit
amount is for someone that earned $2,800
in their base
period
everyone
good um and looking just at a high level
of what the proposal looks to do so it
would uh increase the benefit the weekly
benefit amount for the existing 52 tiers
that are in the statutory table um it
would it would add in two additional
tiers to bring that to 54 um and then it
would add 19 tiers on top of that so um
the 19 tiers would would be added onto
that top tier right now of
41,500 and they would go up in
increments of a th000 um when I first
looked at the proposal I had understood
it to bring that level up to
60,500 for a weekly benefit amount of
753 representative McKenzie has
clarified for me that his intent I
believe is to it's a little bit less
than that I think it's
575 right so 575 but still the same
weekly benefit amount so some of the the
projection work that we do is not
impacted by that but just um so you know
when you see if you see a reference to
6,500 that was uh the Department's uh
confusion and the the top tier that the
representative is looking to bring this
to is 575 from the existing top tier of
415 um so that the new maximum that's
proposed in the bill would be
$753 uh doar a week that would be for
someone that had at least $57,500 in
annual earnings in their base period um
the increases to the existing tiers so
those 52 existing tiers the wage
replacement rate would go up on the
lower tiers to about
70% um right now we're about 60% so
those would go up to 70% and then the
new benefit tiers those 19 new tiers
those would be at a wage replacement
rate of approximately 65% there's a few
that are a little bit higher there's a
few that are a little bit lower but
approximately
65% um now when we go to the next page
and the the pages that follow um but
we're trying to look at what the
experience is of people that are filing
for unemployment so we look at wage
replacement Trends uh since uh 2007 when
the last time the benefits were uh
changed we look at the cost of living
changes over that time period uh we look
at average weekly benefit amount
uh compared to other states we look at
exhaustion rates and duration so
exhaustion rate is when you know how
many people utilize all 26 weeks of
their unemployment benefit and then
duration is how many weeks on average do
people actually file for they have 26
available to them but how many do they
actually file for right now so um when
we flip to the next uh page we get into
uh charts that are more interesting um
than just listen to me speak to words um
but what you can see is that the average
private sector weekly wage compared to
the maximum weekly unemployment benefit
so 2007 that private sector average
weekly wage was right at 852 this is
based upon the administrative filings
from New Hampshire employers um and at
the time uh that was the new Max was was
increased to 427 uh so about a 50% wage
replacement rate for the average private
sector work worker at that point in time
we fast forward to uh uh 2022 uh for the
annual average the annual average
private sector weekly um uh wage was
$1,423 um still the maximum weekly
unemployment benefit at 427 so about a
30% wage replacement rate so you can see
that that 427 uh lost some power over
the course of that time period with the
increases in the average private sector
weekly wage and then we also we did
include the most recent quarter for
which we have this data available in the
third quarter of 23 um you can see that
average weekly wage is about the same as
what it was for the um uh annual average
in 22 um and still about that 30% wage
replacement rate um when we flip uh to
the next uh set of charts we look at the
Consumer Price Index for the Northeast
so um you can see here um in the in the
top chart that Northeast CPI over the
course of 2007 through
2023 has increased just under 40% so
that's looking at the cost of that
basket of goods and what that costs uh
for consumers in the Northeast so that's
a
38.7% increase over that time period yes
Mr chairman a good question was asked
and and I I I kind of gave my clerk an
answer but I'd like to
um yeah I think it's a good question and
something people should know you the
blue graphs on the left side it says are
the private sector weekly wage what
about the non-profit sector or even
government sector why why is it
specifically for that does that mean the
state doesn't play pay we've had layoffs
any you know does the state not pay into
the system like as an
employer um
a bunch of questions there um but no it
was it was just my choice to to include
the private sector rather than including
private plus plus Public public sector W
wages do bring that average um that blue
chart down a little bit I believe we're
down and when you bring in government
you're down in the $1,300 range I'll
look to uh director golob to confirm
whether that's close to being accurate
yeah and and by the way private sector
includes not for-profit it's we're not
it's not a distinction between
for-profit not for profit it's
government versus any organization
that's not a government I uh Mr L I was
um it was under my impression that
government such as Municipal and state
government they do not pay the taxes
they do get unemployment benefits but
then they have to pay those back y yeah
so um real quick so the state as an
employer is a reimbursal so private
sector employ employers are required to
be taxpaying employers that means that
they have to pay at their
experience-based rate on the first
$14,000 in annual wages to each employee
and they pay that quarterly that's a tax
they pay quarterly um state government
they have to file a quarterly report but
they don't pay quarterly tax what they
do is they reimburse for the benefits
that are paid out so when a state
government employee is laid off or is
unemployed employed through no fault of
their own the state then reimburses the
fund dollar for dooll um for the for the
benefits that are paid out for that
individual similar for County um County
government as an employer and municipal
government as an employer the only
difference between the state and County
and municipal government as employers is
that the state is required to be a
reimbursal they can't change that County
and municipal government can elect to be
treated as a taxpaying employer the
default is that they are a reimbursal
what that means is that about 90% of
Municipal and County employers elect to
stay as reimbursing employers they don't
have much in terms of layoff activity um
so it makes sense that they're not
paying quarterly tax um but others have
decided that it's more advantageous for
them to be a taxpaying employer rather
than a reimbursal so that's in a
nutshell how it works uh not for-profits
have that same choice that they can make
that election as well so a a nonprofit
can can uh they are the default is as a
reimbursal and they can elect to be a
taxpaying employer like a a private
sector for-profit employer if they so
choose good question all right thank you
continue oh represent brudy thank you Mr
chairman what if a
nonprofit um starts laying people off
and then they dissolve
and there's no money to
reimburse um so that hand yeah so you
you bring up a very good point
representative and that has been an
issue over over the entire time I've
been with the department and well before
that that you have a nonprofit
institution that that for whatever
reason um closes down and when are those
benefit Charges going to hit after they
close down right um so it becomes
difficult for the Department to recoup
those uh the the reimbursement for those
benefits in some situations um what the
department has done over the years to
try to protect the trust fund is that
when that is occurring the department
does have the ability to put leans on
real estate um other collection measures
that they can take uh um on an emergency
basis to try to protect the the state's
interest in making sure that those
benefit payments while we want to make
them we want to make sure we're
supporting those individuals that are on
employed um but that it's not creating a
disproportionate burden to the trust
fund so that's we you know that's a a I
would welcome that conversation in
another day on ways that we could
perhaps improve that uh situation but uh
that's in a nutshell how we handle it
right
now um just to to close up on the on the
CPI portion of this you'll see in the
bottom chart it just shows the annual uh
the the annual change um and U you can
see that big change obviously in in 2022
with the inflation that we all
experienced um which has has calmed down
um doesn't feel quite like it's calmed
down all that much um in terms of what
we're paying but you can see it down the
23 annual average was 3 and a half% so
half of what we experienced in 22 um
moving uh to the next topic when we flip
to the next set of charts um here we're
looking at average weekly benefit
amounts so before we were talking about
um what the weekly benefit amount that
is connected to the amount of annual
earnings that someone has um and uh how
much of those wages are being replaced
with that weekly benefit amount with the
max being 427 this chart shows what the
average weekly benefit amount is for all
of those people filing for benefits um
and we compare it against other states
so you can you can put it into context
so you can see here New Hampshire's
average weekly benefit amount is about
$353 so the max is $427 the low is 32
but that average is
$353 per week um it's about $80 lower
than the US average uh us average is
about $433 and then you can see some
other northeast states on that top chart
with Massachusetts to the far right
having the highest um average weekly
benefit amount at
$681 uh compared to those other
northeast states the bottom chart is a
little bit uh uh of a u brain hurder
right we have a lot of information here
tried to include the weekly benefit
amounts for for some select States so
you can see um where New Hampshire falls
but that
353 uh puts us to the left of the middle
of that chart uh right in between
Michigan and California um and you can
see Massachusetts again over on that far
right at a 681 average uh weekly benefit
amount again and again this is the
average weekly unemployment benefit
payment that is that is paid out have a
question Sol thank you
um how much we're obviously lower than
average um and but I'm curious if that's
due to the fact that our maximum benefit
is so low or is it because the um the
benefits below the maximum are also
lower than
normal um so a very good question um
what you'll see is that um we actually
have some um data here to show the
actual experience from claim filers in
2023 and you'll see that a significant
number of those claim filers are getting
grouped in the 427 Max weekly benefit
amount because their earnings are are
well above uh 41,5 so that that 353 is
is depressed by the fact that our
maximum benefit is is lower
I I have a question I didn't know if you
had an opportunity I I brought this up
at The Advisory Board committee one of
the things it's difficult to understand
by looking at this if you just look at
the the chart that shows New Hampshire
being the lowest here
um are all these are all the other New
England states taxing the same amount of
wages are is this 14,000 per employee
are they all consistent or higher lower
um they are not consistent so um and we
have some charts that try to equalize
this across States so each state has a
slightly different mechanism for for how
they set rates for purposes of
unemployment compensation taxes how they
um they how they experience rate the
Employers in that state they have
slightly different taxable wage bases so
New Hampshire's taxable wage base is
$144,000 per employee per year and
whatever your rate is is your experience
based rate and for a new employer that's
2.7% uh you're paying that on that first
14,000 per employee per year we have
some charts that look at some um trying
to compare Apples to Apples by looking
at total unemployment taxes paid by
Employers in each state compared against
total wages paid in each state and
you'll see from lows where New Hampshire
falls um we can we can provide um a a
chart
Mr chairman that shows the the taxable
wage base uh for each state the only
caveat I would have there is that the
the way that the the rates are set in
each state is slightly different so just
because a State might have a taxable
wage base of um
$40,000 if their the rate at which
they're setting is much lower than the
mechanism in New Hampshire um it doesn't
give you a it's not a clear picture that
just because that taxable wage base is
that much higher that the overall amount
being paid is going to be higher you
don't have to answer this now but when I
look at a chart like this and I have an
outlier I like to understand why is it
just that Massachusetts pay
significantly more or is it based on the
amount that the people pay the employers
pay in and all those different things
but that that's a discussion for a
different day but yeah and you and
you'll see when we get into looking at
some of the the um maximum weekly
benefit amounts available by state
you'll see where New Hampshire falls but
here looking at average weekly benefit
amount new Hampshire is low in the
Northeast um but when you look in the
National context um you know it it's um
we're 19th lowest um in the country so
trying to put it in the context of where
we sit um and also uh the country as a
whole thank you um when we flip to the
next uh charts we look at exhaustion
rates and duration so um obviously the
amount of unemployment benefits being
paid and the overall condition of the
state's economy have an impact on how
many people are exhausting their
unemployment benefits uh meaning that
they file for all 26 weeks that are
available for them uh New Hampshire has
a very low exhaustion rate um and
continues to have the lowest exhaustion
rate in the country so on the on the top
chart you can see New Hampshire at 11%
so 11% of filers utilize all 26 weeks um
how that Stacks up against some other
states um in that um across the country
and then the chart below that includes
all of the states but New Hampshire has
historically had one of the lowest
exhaustion rates in the country and
right now has the lowest um exhaustion
rate in the country um looking at
average duration so the number of weeks
um that a person collects unemployment
benefits in New Hampshire compared to
other states so again you have 26 weeks
available um but right now as you'll see
in that top chart New Hampshire's
average duration is 10 weeks so 26
available average filer is filing for 10
weeks um and that puts uh New Hampshire
as having the lowest duration in the
Northeast um and then in the bottom
chart you can see that that puts us in
as having the ninth lowest average
duration in the entire country and you
can see where some of the other states
fall um in terms of that
duration um when we flip to the next uh
set of charts and this is getting to uh
chairman infantine uh one of the points
he was making so here you can see that
when we look at the maximum weekly
benefit amount um from state to state um
New Hampshire's is
427 um what that
427 um maximum weekly benefit amount
translates when compared against other
states is that is it is the 19th lowest
maximum benefit in the country um so you
got 18 states that have a lower um
maximum weekly benefit amount and you
can see those States in that top chart
and then when we look only at the
Northeast um you can see that even
though we're um 19th lowest in the
country um we are the lowest in the
Northeast so at 427 in New Hampshire
your maximum weekly benefit amount um
ver uh New York is at 504
and then far to the right uh New
Hampshire uh Massachusetts here would be
the outlier at having a maximum weekly
benefit amount of over
$1,400 um and this does include um a lot
of states have dependency allowances so
that if you you have uh you know for the
for however many children uh that you
have or dependence you're allowed an
additional amount of weekly benefits
that includes all of that New Hampshire
does not have that so uh most of those
other states do Massachusetts does um
but that shows you the maximum weekly
benefit amount available and how New
Hampshire Compares um to our neighbors
in the
Northeast um when we flip to the next
set of charts um this these two charts
try to show where New Hampshire would
fall if House Bill 1522 were passed so
um we have the the 19th lowest um
maximum weekly benefit amount currently
and if House Bill 1522 were passed we
would have the eighth highest maximum
weekly benefit amount uh that amount as
proposed is
$753 a week so that's about a 75%
increase from our current ma uh maximum
weekly benefit amount and would put us
as having eighth highest in the country
however when you look at the bottom
chart with these two charts um it still
has us at the bottom of the Northeast um
so at 753 we would be the third lowest U
maximum weekly B benefit amount in the
Northeast with New York and Vermont
being lower than us but Connecticut uh
still being slightly higher Maine being
um up at 894 um so Maine being on the on
the right hand side not near
Massachusetts um in dollar amount but
near Massachusetts in ranking uh there
um now when we flip to the next side of
pages we're going to um look at the
other side of the unemployment benefit
system but get to the revenue side um to
look at the taxes being paid by
employers that go into our trust fund
and again it's it's a 100% employer
funded system uh for the payment of
unemployment benefits we'll look at what
the trend in employer tax rates has been
um we'll do some national comparison for
that what that overall unemployment tax
burden is on New Hampshire employers
compared to other states um and then
we'll look at our current trust fund
forecast and then we'll get into into um
looking at what the proposal um in House
Bill 1522 uh would do to the uh uh
current trust fund and we do some stress
testing uh for folks so you can see what
the impact would be um but real quick on
that bottom chart looking at what the
annual average uh quarterly average uh
tax rate for employers has done and we
are back to pre-pandemic levels um so uh
Q3 of
2023 that average rate that an employer
is paying on that first $14,000 in
annual wages to each employee is
0.57% uh so we were back below where we
were uh prior to the pandemic and that
0.57% translates to about $80 per
employee per year that is being paid uh
by that
employer um when we flip um to the next
set of charts this is where we try to
equalize it a little bit and um US
government does publish data on trying
to um do that Apple's Apple's comparison
for overall unemployment insurance tax
burdens across from state to state and
so what again they look at they look at
total unemployment taxes paid compared
against total wages paid um and when you
do that and you see this top chart you
see that New Hampshire has the 14th
lowest UI tax burden in the country and
um that top chart shows the states um
that are lower so although New Hampshire
is on the far right of that top chart
that is not where we fall now nationally
nor in in the Northeast um but you can
see those other states that have a lower
overall UI tax burden um in terms of how
much is paid in UI tax um when we when
we look down at the bottom chart you'll
see that um when we look in the
Northeast um New Hampshire's overall UI
tax burden at
0.27% is the lowest in the Northeast um
and surprisingly Massachusetts is right
right next to us on that at 0
4% um um director Dr golob and I were
actually talking about that the other
day and and Massachusetts does
historically deplete their trust funds
and they depend on borrowing from the
federal government to pay benefits when
we get hit with an economic downturn uh
so I think that's why you see them at
point4 um they certainly don't have a
solvent trust fund um which is an
important factor to take into
consideration but looking at so that
gives you a better sense of how New
Hampshire employers are doing compared
to Employers in other states from a UI
tax burden perspective
um and when we turn the page you can see
our our current state of our trust fund
so this is this is the state
unemployment compensation trust fund
this is where the taxes paid by
employers and the reimbursed dollars
from those government employers and
those nonprofits those dollars go into
our trust fund it does not sit here in
New Hampshire um as representative
mckeny had indicated had pointed out
this is this sits with Washington this
sits with US Treasury um in New
Hampshire draws down on this on a daily
basis um to pay benefits um but these
are New Hampshire's dollars um these are
these do not belong to any other state
uh the the trust fund dollars are New
Hampshire's and only can be paid for
benefit recipients in New Hampshire uh
so so right now um we are in the almost
$400 million range uh we forecast a
quarter ending balance I say we I have
no part of that whatsoever that we
is the uh economic and labor market
information Bureau headed headed up by
director golob here um but they are
forecasting that we will that we will
stay close to $400 million and then at
the end of uh
2025 um we will sustain a balance for
one quarter that is above $400 million
which would then increase the amount of
a discount applied to um employers tax
rates so employers they get a series of
discounts they get a um to whatever your
rate is you cannot pay below
.1% um but you have a series of
discounts that if the fund maintains a
balance of at least $250 million you get
a 0.5 reduction to your rate so if
you're a new employer starting at a 2.7%
rate that brings you down to
2.2 and if we maintain a balance of $350
for an entire quarter $350 million that
brings your rate down by 1% so that new
employer at 2.7 would be down to 1.7
that's where we're currently at um we
are currently at a 1% discount on
employer tax rates because we've
maintained a balance above 350 million
but we have not hit that $400 million
Mark which is that top threshold so when
we maintain 400 million employers
receive a 1.5% reduction to their tax
rate so that new employer starting at 27
that employer would get brought down to
1.2 if we were to hit that
1.5% now we are looking we are
forecasting that we will maintain a
balance over that um but when you're
talking a few million dollars on a $400
million account and we're looking out
towards the end of 25 um that is a
projection that will likely be missed
either to the South or to the north of
that um we're never exact we're not
quite as close as uh secretary of state
scandin was with his uh number of I
think he was off by a thousand voters in
the Republican primary I thought he did
pretty good with that um we might not be
as close there but it's you know it
could uh be a little bit under that 400
400 million Mark could be a little bit
higher um but that's our our um forecast
at the current Point um and then um with
that I did I think representative K Hill
you had a
question thank you uh with the higher
wages that we've seen
the employers are hitting that maximum
pretty quickly aren't they the maximum
that they'll be taxed on correct yeah so
that so it's the first 14,000 in annual
earnings per employee that they pay at
that experience rate yep so when you
have when you're um paying more and you
don't have seasonal patterns to your
your employment a lot of that tax is
being paid as a as a result of your
first quarter maybe a little bit in your
second quarter so that when you have
another another discount that employer
isn't benefiting because he's already
paid he's already done yeah so that's a
very good point one I should have made
um if you know if you're not seeing uh
the additional discount applied until a
later quarter in the year you know
you're if you're your traditional
employment pattern is flat and you don't
have a seasonal mix to that um you're
you're going to hit your your full
amount of unemployment insurance tax in
those first two quarters so when
Employment Security comes back and says
hey hey we got a 1 and a half% discount
for you in the fourth quarter um it
might not mean that much to you if it
sticks around for the first quarter it
certainly does but it might not mean
that much for the majority of employers
when it hits in say the third or the
fourth quarter thank
you um and with that I'll I'll turn it
over to director golob to bring us
through some of the projections that
he's done um looking at House Bill 1522
and and the impact that it would have on
the trust
fund um I'll
um
well I'll skip through some some of this
first uh segment here and and go to the
page after that because that's really
gets at the heart of how we model this
um the first thing I should say is that
we did look at actual claims from the
first three quarters of
2023 and applied the new benefit
schedule to see what the implications
would be and as you can see from the
chart um benefit payments would have
risen about
47% during that time period um that's a
lot a really significant increase um but
I will also say that it in a lot of ways
it minimizes what the impact overall
will be in over the longer term because
the first three quarters of 2023 were a
very good year we had very low levels of
claims um and we had people who filed
for benefits for a very short period of
time so that all minimized
the amount of payments that were going
out in a situation where the payments
were made for longer periods of time in
a weaker economy uh more claims the the
likely implications would be larger um
the next chart just shows um and it gets
at some of the I think really important
points that have been made here um
representative uh Sullivan made a point
about um the impact that capping at 415
41,500 uh as the maximum earnings that
someone can have before they reach the
maximum benefit payment um that number
has increased pretty significantly over
the time period that was last changed
2007 2007 it was many fewer individuals
reaching that number now it is many more
so what you see in this chart is half
over half the individuals during that
time period that we looked at the
January to September time period 56%
were above that
415 that
41,500 the effect of that of course is
to lower the overall wage replacement
ratio because you got a bunch of people
who are getting a much smaller
percentage if you look at the benefit
schedule as it is right now the
52 levels that we have the replacement
ratio the wage replacement ratio is
exactly the same as it was in 2007 no
impact it's people who earn above
41,500 where the wage replacement ratio
because it the maximum amount is
$427 over the next 16 years that
effective replacement ratio has gone
down because people's earnings we have
more people making earning higher levels
so that's having a big impact on the
wage replacement ratio it's having a big
impact on the average benefit and there
a big reason why our aage average
benefit payment is as low as it is so
that's a kind of a long explanation and
there you see um the the uh the you I
can't what was this one I can't even
remember what this one oh this next
chart just looks at if if you took the
same clim claim filing population from
2023 that director golob had just
mentioned and you plug them into
representative McKenzie's wage uh
benefits schedule instead of that 4,100
hitting the max of 427 you'd have about
32% hit that Max so about 2,300 would
hit that new Max of 753 so they would
need to have at least uh
57,500 in base period earnings um but
you'd have you still have over 2,300
individuals or about 32% rather than 56%
hitting that
Max thank you um the next chart begins
our process of taking a look at what
would happen under the new benefit
schedule first thing we did was we did a
backcast basically we plugged in the new
benefit schedule to our actual claims
history um from
2021 Q4 through 2023 Q3 and we have um a
rather complex economic model
econometric model um that does this
forecasting so when we plug in the new
benefit schedule and it there is some
assumptions involved in that um what we
found is that our trust fund would have
performed it would have had a balance at
about $65 million lower than it
currently has so that's using actual
numbers when we look forward we're
making some assumptions about what the
claims levels will be um and we've done
that under a few different scenarios the
first one is that forecast that we
showed you in a few charts ago of
$393 million ending balance for Q4 2025
that's our Baseline forecast that
Baseline forecast by the way includes
some uptick and claims over the next few
quarters we expect the the labor market
will slow a little bit no recession but
it will pick up some so when we plug in
the new benefit schedule into that we
wind up with
a a impact Act of about $50 million less
on the on the trust fund there are some
assumptions that I think um and this is
really getting into the weeds I do think
this is a little bit optimistic for the
forecast for the new benefit schedule
for one big reason there's a recognition
that um when you increase benefits
significantly you tend to increase the
length of time of uh that individuals
are unemployed it becomes a little and
and this I don't want this to sound
harsh but but people if they're a little
bit more comfortable then not they're
not comfortable losing their job for
sure but you know we see it in in states
that have very high pen benefit payments
we see the duration is a little bit
longer and that's not my view that's
generally recognized in economic
research that the more generous the
payments are generally that will
increase the length of time that
individuals that was not included in
this so we made we made this forecast
basically assuming there would be no
impact um and when I say we made that
assumption it was because it was very
hard to include that into the model
maybe in future iterations we'll be able
to do that but it's clear that it would
have some impact on the duration of
employment and if we factor that in I
think the impacts on the trust fund
would be greater Mr go we have a
question go ahead mam thank you Mr chair
um I've had this question from a few
slides ago on it's the flip side of what
you're saying do we have a sense when we
look at that you know like I think it
was
10% um is how many folks Go the whole
duration 11% so we're one of the lowest
um do we have a and I imagine if folks
are getting a lower rate they can't
afford there is a pressure to get a job
right away but do we have a sense
as to for example in in representative
McKenzie's example at Berlin you know I
can imagine in the in the example he
cites you're not making a better wage
than you did before you were unemployed
right so do you have a sense of how that
correlates to or how our wages correlate
to how it is of getting off of
unemployment into a new job is better
worse equal I'm
suspecting it's worse um I don't now
although that is part of an evaluation
process that we're looking at going at
at going through um that's required by
the Department of Labor basically uh
taking a look at what happens to
individuals after they file for
unemployment how quickly they get off
what happens in terms of their wages do
do they get more um an increase in wages
do they do their wages suffer and that's
part to evaluate the you know the
Reemployment Services that we provide um
but I can't say right now off the top of
my head I know that and I my guess is it
varies pretty significantly by by region
um you know representative McKenzie
mentioned the the paper mill well there
weren't many jobs that probably paid a
lot better than the paper mill up there
um so I do think that there there is
some impact and I I will say that part
of the reason why we have such a low
exhaustion rate is not just related to
our benefit schedule it's related to the
strength of our economy you know we have
we have a much higher job openings rate
than the nation overall so we have a
strong economy and when you have a
stronger economy that duration rate
regardless of your of your benefit
schedule it's going to likely Aid in
getting people back into the workforce
more
quickly Mr got L okay I'll take the
questions and then I'm going to have you
wrap it up in the next five minutes as
so representative St followed by U um
thank you uh for taking my question um
my question is as you are calculating uh
the amount of money that's going to be
in the trust fund are you including the
discount
rates yes oh yeah the the FBI that has a
big impact I mean the benefit schedule
has a number of pretty complex impacts
obviously we know what happens with the
payment schedule that's very that's the
easiest part to forecast but the other
big impact is f the fund balance
reductions we know that the harder part
is what's going to happen to employer
tax rates and that's going to be as
significant as the benefit payment side
of it because we know we're going to be
paying out more that gets mitigated we
didn't just take that additional amount
that's being paid out and subtract it
from our Baseline forecast we had to
make um assumptions and it when I say
assumptions it's based on the you know
20 some years of of economic
relationships the data that we use to
put into this model but what's going to
happen is employers are going to be
paying more so that mitigates some of
the um impact on the trust fund so
there's a lot of complex things they all
do go in here the one thing again that
hasn't gone in here is what is the
impact on the amount of time that
individuals are going to spend on
unemployment that's the part that right
now our model doesn't
incorporate kale followed by love thank
you Mr chair and thank you Mr car uh
so is it logical to to to think that
someone who's making you know close to
60,000 is a lot better prepared you know
if they're living somewhere within their
means than someone who's making 25,000
to weather uh a period of
unemployment I mean I guess in theory
that's the case um they also have the
low a much lower wage replacement ratio
in our in our current system so they may
have greater incentive to find
employment quicker somebody making
$60,000 is you know their wage
replacement ratio is going to be
somewhere you know below 40% or 30 some
percent so um but uh that in theory I
guess hire hire individ individuals who
are H earning higher incomes generally
have more opportunities um they have
more opportunities they tend to have
higher levels of educational attainment
generally have more um Reemployment
opportunities followup followup
um so if we were to I think
representative McKenzie already thought
that his his proposal was a little bit
high if we were to split the difference
we'd still have we would have a uh a
better uh balance in the trust fund and
less of a of a whack to our employers
who are paying but they still they're
only being taxed this rate half a
percent or whatever uh on the first
14,000 does that number me need to be
um we can model um what those because
you got a lot of levers here right to
you know when you change one um it's
going to have some impact and um you try
to isolate that so you can understand it
each change the best but we can model um
what those changes would be uh probably
the easiest one to model rather than
getting into uh projecting out rates the
easiest one to model is taxable wage
base changes um you know there was some
discussion with the advisory Council on
Monday on that point so that something
that can be modeled and look at what the
overall impact would be um just to get
to your prior question representative as
well it's interesting that when you look
at the overall condition of the people
that were utilizing the unemployment
program in
2023 that the the first benefit tier
that had at least 100 filers over the
course of those nine months um was not
at the those uh super low benefit tiers
it was all the way up at $22,000 a year
um so that was the the first benefit
tier that had at least 100 people but
you know most of them were at that 427
and and a lot of the lower benefit tiers
I think the bottom five didn't have a
single filer um in them over the course
of those first nine
months thank
you love followed by represent directo
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question um does New Hampshire have a
a uh Provisions in its unemployment
program to uh allow for workers to uh
unemployed workers to work part-time or
find a a lesser paying job temporarily
and have it not affect their their um
unemployment benefits yeah U and we'll
get into we'll get into a lot of that
with um uh representative Sullivan's
bill that's coming up next um so New
Hampshire just to answer that quickly
New Hampshire does allow um individuals
while filing for unemployment benefits
to have part-time employment
not full-time employment that is not
allowed by the federal government but
you allowed to have part-time employment
and you need to report that work in
those earnings while you're
collecting up uh would it be beneficial
to the state and to the the fund and uh
employers if we uh you know we raise
that uh that uh the cap on that uh so
somebody could uh could make essentially
make a little more money rather than um
rather than affect the the uh the trust
fund and I think you have a supporter of
that with representative Sullivan judged
by House Bill 1597 be the next Bill
thank
youo thank you I I just have a couple
questions um on the modest recess
recession graph oh yeah okay we we're
going to address that yes okay yeah then
I can wa if I could just I got two more
slides that I want to cover because we
did we showed you what the impact would
be in our base case scenario um but what
really what is uh of interest is what
would happen in different economics Areo
so we modeled two ways one is a modest
recession what's a modest recession is
basically the recession that we had in
the early 2000s and how we did this was
we took the actual rate of of Ben
benefit claims that were being paid
adjusted that for the current number of
people who are employed and then ran ran
the model that way and what you see is
um you know with the with the the
current benefits schedule the trust fund
takes about a $60 million hit around $60
million um with the new benefit schedule
what happens is we take another $85
million hit um beyond that um with the
new Under the new benefit schedule and
again to some degree this probably is a
little bit optimistic because in a
recession we're going to have a higher
uh uh you know uh number of weeks that
are claimed and we didn't we didn't
figure that in the next page is even
scarier is what happens um in a severe
recession what's a severe recession we
modeled same way with the Great
Recession took the actual number of
claims ran that through the model what
it would look like with the current
number of employment employees even with
the current benefit schedule you know
that was a severe recession the the the
trust fund us loses $260 million under
the new benefit schedule it gets down to
kind of dangerously low levels of 78
million and again there's margin for
error but I think that's optimistic
because in a severe recession what
you're going to see is a lot of people
filing for a lot longer than 10 or 11
weeks and that's concludes my comment
and I would just add to that and there
are some other slides with some some of
our takeaways from the modeling you can
take a look at them and and help maybe
um um inform your thoughts around some
of the information presented but when
you look at the the the model of the
severe recession so so the Great
Recession um the the good news on that
chart is that when you look at what our
current benefits schedule what the
projected depletion of the UN
unemployment trust fund would look like
getting down to 160 million that's good
performance um that is what the governor
and the legislature wanted when the
changes were made to budget cycle ago uh
to those trust fund uh discount triggers
when those discount triggers were raised
uh from their old amounts up to the
current amounts up to 350 and 400
million there was a recognition that
true solvency was up in the $400 million
range in order for New Hampshire to be
able to pay benefits during a a severe
recession and not have to rely upon the
federal government and that's what that
performance right there shows is that we
stay above that $150 million Mark which
used to be the line of uhoh we're in
trouble because that's when there used
to be additional sear charges that
kicked in on employer rates at that
point when you look at the impact of The
Proposal without any accompanying
Revenue changes getting down below 80
million that's that's at a point where
80 million sounds like a lot to me
sounds like a lot to to Brian um because
we we're both state government employees
um but when you're at that point in the
rate at which you are paying out
benefits you do not have time to act you
are almost guaranteed to have to borrow
from the federal government and maybe
it'll be a point in time where borrowing
is made easy because plenty of other
states are doing it and they've loosened
the rules around the costs to States
however um when you look at the
potential cost to States when you do
borrow um you're running the risk of
having to pay borrowing costs um if you
don't pay pay those funds back quickly
enough the federal government charges
the state interest and they also start
to increase the federal unemployment
rate at which employers are paying their
federal unemployment tax so they they
try to come down hard on States um and
penalize those States and incentivize
them to pay back those borrowed funds
quickly by making it painful what we saw
last time with a Great Recession a lot
of States bonded that debt so they they
could get out from under the the
problems that the federal government
would create for their Employers in the
state instead they bonded it they didn't
get away from the debt they still have
to pay it but they they got away from
owing it to US Treasury um and having
the accompanying penalties to their
employers so just some things to think
about and looking at that that Great
Recession uh type
you
so looking at the the modest
recession um so did you factor that the
two if if this were to pass the 252
million was that factored on the 11 or
the 10 weeks average of benefits or did
you increase that we did not increase
that and that's why I'm I'm think in any
of the recession scenarios they're
likely a little bit optimistic for right
for the trust fund because you know
exactly how what impact that will be um
we know in a recession the the the you
know the duration of unemployment goes
up what that would be we didn't factor
into the model model right now is not
capable of doing that but we will make
modifications to allow
it so you kind of equated it to 2008
recession well the the modest was it was
early 2000 2002 okay was it was a little
bit stronger in New Hampshire than
nationally but it was consider
considered a relatively mild recession
are there numbers for how long people
filed during that time period there is
there is um and I but we just the way
the model is constructed it's not
capable of doing that over a period of
time until we make modifications but it
was longer it was longer yes yes and
during the Great Recession significantly
longer it took us six years to get back
all the employment that we lost during
the gravy session wow and we can provide
that data the average duration going
back to both of those time periods
that's so so likely the number will Pro
the amount in the trust F will probably
be lower I would guess it will be lower
not to mention the fact it's going to be
harder to find a job during recession
and now if you're getting more money it
it's probably not quite as incentivized
to try to find another job so it's
probably pretty high the the number here
I would guess is probably going to
be I say substantially I don't know
Millions higher than what it really is
but and then so so my next question
would be when the trust fund drops that
much what I forget the acronym to FBR
FBR fund balance reduction what will be
the new employer costs assuming even if
it was at 250 million which will likely
be lower than that what would what would
be the employer take now um so the the
employers would pay at their true
experience rate so um right now you get
that reduction whatever the fund balance
reduction uh dictates so right now
they're getting that 1% reduction so you
look at our the the table that had the
average rate of
0.57 right now um if you remove that FBR
those employers would be at
1.57 uh right now would be that average
rate okay so then and and a new employer
they come in at 2.7 and then get
adjusted based on the FBR for those
first four quarters so they would be at
2.7 so I so you would just take the if
it was an existing employer you would
just take the
14,000 and just multiply it by I can't
do the math in my head right now but
1.5% and that's roughly what they'll pay
per year uh per employee per year
correct okay so it will increase the
cost to an employer during a
recession absolutely yes okay and that
doesn't include whatever their
experience rate
might dictate over the course of the
year if they have a lot of layoffs the
next time it's determined determined
annually they would their rate would go
up as well okay thank you repr kale
thank you Mr chair and thank you uh so
if you're an employer that's not prone
to layoffs you're probably going to be
in pretty good shape even if this worst
case scenario happens as far as your
expenses a 1.5 time you know at for you
get 14% or
14,000 right if so if you're an employer
that regardless of the economic downturn
you're not laying off individual so your
experience isn't going to um um get
worse because there aren't benefits
going out to your former employees um
but your experience will might actually
improve a little bit because you're
going to have more taxes coming in if
you're one of those that don't have any
layoffs but you're going to lose the
fund balance reduction so instead of
paying at 0.57% you're going to be
triple that or close to Triple that at
1.57 uh perc on the first $144,000 per
employee follow up and I I don't believe
you're an accountant but I'll ask anyway
so are all these expenses deductible you
write them off against your uh B uh bet
and the bft and your federal and
everything else all these reduce your
tax burden in a sense you another tax um
I will defer to the Department of
Revenue on BET and
BPT um deductions and impacts for
purposes of our statute the employer is
required to report all way AG is paid
for each and every employee each quarter
and that and that's the amount that they
are taxed upon and the amounts that then
go into factoring into their experience
rate thank
you all right seeing no other questions
we have one more oh I'm sorry I'm sorry
a question for chair I have a lot of
questions for gentl I have a lot of
questions for um Mr laas and Mr go are
they be testifying on the next R because
I don't want this to run late because it
it will be in in depth delve into the
trust
fund well I can't go to the next one and
then come back and ask
questions
um I clarify yes testimon be the same on
the
next somewhat but not a lot it really
has to do with how much money you can
earn so so um why don't you take uh we
have one more speaker why don't you
take yeah had a few of
these if I feel that they're droning on
I will let you ask them privately okay
uh thank you Mr chairman again thank you
Mr labors and Mr gotot Le um as we've
seen over the trust fund from since um I
look at 2011 and 2020 as being outliers
um if we increase benefits the duration
will increase the costs increased
unemployment insurance would increase
the trust fund balance would obviously
have to be increased in order to absor
to take that initial hit of unemployment
claims in another recession um can you
explain the balance between the positive
and negative and how that would impact
um positive um UI Insurance payers and
negative UI Insurance payers and what
the rates could look like if it went to
a $500 million trust fund in order to
not drop below the 100 million that in
your
graphs here I mean it's it's a little
bit involved but I it's a question
that's been rotating around thank
you um yes
so if Ben if the amount of benefits
being paid out uh increases then that is
um applied against your experience rate
that's a that's a negative on your
experience um so your overall experience
rate is going to be going up the way
that New Hampshire sets that right now
is is we we have three tables that are
in the unemployment compensation statute
so the first table with the lower rates
the lowest rates the lowest of which
that you can pay at is
0.1% um that is the table for positive
rated employers um so representative
avalani had talked about positive and
negative so positive rated employers are
those that have paid in more in taxes
into the program then that we have paid
out in benefits to their former
employees um they are less of a risk to
the trust fund therefore they are
provided with the lowest tax rates the
next table is for those employers that
are newly negative so if you are
negative rated for less than four years
then say you had um uh disruption um to
uh your supply chain something that
caused you to have to lay off a portion
of your Workforce that causes you to go
into the point of being negative where
now we have paid out more in
unemployment benefits to your former
employees than you have paid in in taxes
you go to table two in the statute with
slightly higher rates and then for those
that are chronically negative so
negative for more than four years those
that really have seasonal patterns to
their hiring and firing uh those
employers pay at the highest uh the
rates at the highest table uh with the
experience rate there the maximum is
7% um additionally a negative rated
employer does have sear charges um that
kick in they they're an inverse SE
charge so they work um opposite of the
fund balance reductions for positive
rated employers so when the fund is
below 250 million and positive rated
employers are paying at their experience
rate they don't get any reduction those
negative rated employers get a 1 and a
half% inverse search charge on their
rate as the fund goes up and positive
rated employers see their rates go down
with the fund balance uh reduction those
negative rated employers get less of a
sech charge added onto their rate and
when we're at that $400 million Mark
they have zero sirch charge and the
positive rated employers have the 1 and
a half% maximum
reduction so when you're not hitting
those those thresholds in the trust fund
that means that the fund balance
reductions are not being met with which
then increases rates and when you have
more being paid out in benefits you're
going to have a negative impact on
experience which will result in higher
rate higher rates and higher taxes as
well and a quick followup yes sir thank
you and thank you for the followup um so
when the trust fund balance reaches a
certain level uh in law it does an
automatic increase to employers say and
but all employers pay that increase no
matter what whether their experience is
positive or negative if we hit we get
sorry the employeers get hit with this
trigger this trigger this trigger which
could in turn obviously if we have a
larger swing in our model for um
unemployment benefits at with using this
we would see a lot of those triggers
happening on a slow year or even on a
large year large unemployment year those
swings would be very large for unemploy
for employers to catch up on if let's
say it happens in the third quarter and
a lot of them have already paid into
their thing come the first quarter of
the following year there's going to be a
large increase in their unemployment
insurance benefits uninsurance payments
and and and though the the fund balance
reductions They do change from quarter
to quarter um it's usually for the the
benefit of the employer right because
it's a it's a reduction to your
experience rate um and I know the um tax
Foundation dings New Hampshire every
year when they give their ratings for
the the tax climate of the state because
it can change quarter to quarter even
though it's usually to the benefit of
the employer they don't like it
um I disagree with them Brian and I have
talked with them um uh but so we look in
order to determine that fund balance
reduction you're always looking at the
prior quarters daily balance in the
trust fund so we track the daily balance
we don't forecast the daily balance but
we track the daily balance and as long
as the daily balance for the prior
quarter um equal or exceeded $250
million that subsequent quarter
employers get that point .5 reduction or
that 0.1 or that 1.0 reduction if it's
350 million and that 1.5 reduction if
it's 400 million now it's quarter by
quarter so it can change quarter by
quarter right now we've been in a a
pretty uh constant state of 1% 1% 1%
reductions quarter to quarter um but it
does we do inform employers at the end
of each quarter um what that rate is
going to be what what FBR is in effect
for that next quarter goes out with the
the uh their their tax rates in their um
tax reports when they go out thank you
thank you you're
welcome see no more questions uh Brian I
need you to fill out one of those pink
cards for me uh we have one uh last
speaker on this um before we move to the
next bill uh excuse me uh David pelet
waiting turn your mic
off your mic's off
sorry all right so good morning Mr
chairman members of the committee my
name is David peler I live in dumart New
Hampshire I'm the business manager of
plumbers and pip Fitters Local 131 and a
representative of the New Hampshire
building and construction trades and I'm
here in support of help Bill
um I I certainly uh don't envy the work
you're going to have to do because this
is an incredibly
complicated um issue that you're dealing
with here but I can tell you from the
perspective of my members and the
members of the other Building Trades you
know filing for unemployment
compensation is is something that you
know you have to do from time to time
jobs end uh people get laid off through
no fault of their own they file for
unemployment compensation and the
current rate of
1427 that we heard for the last 17 years
it's just it's
insufficient um you know that that 1427
equates the 1708 a month with current
rates in the state of New Hampshire at
$1,500 a month and up I mean how can how
can we expect people to pay their bills
uh you know know support their families
pay insurance pay for
utilities um it it's just it just can't
be done so in effect what we're what
we're doing and I see it with my members
and other Building Trades
Representatives see with their members
our members you know they don't want to
collect unemployment to regardless but
when they have to I have members who
don't want to work out of state and and
this just happened two weeks ago I had a
member got got laid off from a job at at
lonza
pharmaceutical he called up you know I
I'm looking to work here in New
Hampshire um so I don't even want to go
down to Massachusetts well three weeks
later I mean he saying you know I can't
afford I gotta pay for my rent I'm
married I got a kid I I got to go to
work they go to Massachusetts I have
personally with the plumbers and pipe
fitters we have 50 some members working
down there and once they go there um you
know we we the commute is awful the
hours you know aren't good but the
amount of money they make over the New
Hampshire scale you know for my trade
alone is $20 an hour and then once they
get laid off down there you we've heard
what their unemployment rate is they end
up saying you know what I'll just wait
for another job down here I can't make
it in New Hampshire anymore and we get
more and more workers crossing the
border every day um you know and
certainly increasing the unemployment U
amount is not going to make workers stay
here but it I I believe it will help and
it'll help with workers who are here and
want to be here um you know support
themselves in their time of need that's
that's really all the uh testimony I
you let see any questions thank you very
much hanging out for an hour and a half
thank you and good luck I have no other
ping cards does anyone like to speak on
House Bill
1522 seeing none uh get this thing in
the you know these uh online testimony
submission support 28 oppose one Z
neutral okay no
neutrals I'm going to open the hearing
on House Bill
1597 and um recognize is representative
the the only ones were the two people
that
spoke I
know still I need
sign welcome to the labor
committee uh thank you chairman and
thank you MERS of the committee this is
my very first presentation for any sort
of bill so uh be nice to me I guess um
okay so this bill obviously related to
what you guys just talked to in the pr
talked about in the previous bill but
it's it's a little bit different so I
actually stumbled across this problem by
getting laid off at the beginning of
last year um or the beginning of 200
yeah last year I I I got on to
unemployment for the first time and
through that process I discovered things
that I think are unfortunate and a
disincentive to getting people back to
work so that led to me the motivation to
me putting in this bill
so when I I do I'm an economist and I do
Consulting and I believe heavily in in
incentives and incentives to get people
back to work is sort of the driving
force behind this bill so when I was uh
working at this company and then I got
laid off I didn't have enough time to
really get enough Consulting to support
myself and I was on unemployment and
then I would get periodic Consulting
contracts and you got to declare
whatever income you earn and so what I
quickly realized was in the way the
structure is currently if you do work
while like part-time you know I I had
one contract that was like 12 hours and
it quickly put me over what I would make
in this and I just I just got kicked out
of the program um and had to go through
the refiling process but and that's fine
if you're making more than what you get
then that doesn't bother me as much as
if you work and you go beyond the 30% um
allowed wages before you start losing
some of your benefits you're actually
have zero incentive once you hit that
that 30% of what your benefits are that
to me doesn't feel right and and the
reason it doesn't feel right is for
example sometimes when I when I don't
have Consulting work I'll do I'll do
substitute teaching which is about $90 a
day so if I if I did I had the maximum
amount which was what $427 or something
so if I did two days of Consulting I was
actually worse off than if I just did
one not Consulting of substitute
teaching than if I just did one day of
substitute teaching because they take
off that full $90 but there's obviously
taxes taken out and I spent the whole
day working and my and it's just dollar
for dollar taken off of my unemployment
benefits so that to me is is a problem
so I I've changed the thing the the bill
and the amendment that I passed around
to you guys uh the initial bill I'm sure
you've all experienced it if you put in
Bill sometimes it's a little Lost in
Translation with OS and and um so it
ended up being a little bit more
complicated what you guys got than what
I intended and so I got this revision so
it's really the only thing that's
different from this amendment from the
actual bill that you guys have seen is
at the top of the actual bill there was
a bunch of stuff like crossed out that's
back in I wasn't trying to change any of
that I was just trying to change the
formula so the formula now reads all
wages and earnings in excess of 30%
rounded to nearest Dollar of the
individual's weekly benefit will be
deducted from from your unemployment
benefit I change that to 40% of of any
earned wages rounded to the nearest
Dollar so if we have let's say you're
making for simple math $300 a week in
unemployment benefits and you earn1 $100
just for easy math you get to keep
pretty much all of that money right but
if you earn
$200 you a 100 of it will be taken off
of your
$300 under this formula we would be
taking off 40% of that $200 so 80 $80
would be deducted so you're actually a
little bit better which I think um is it
representative Mason or no represent
love you you sort of had this idea do we
change the the formula and that's what I
was getting at because to me it seems a
I was coming from somebody who I was
only getting single percentage
percentage um of my income in the
unemployment and so if I could have
worked a little bit more and got some
and kept a little bit higher share of my
unemployment it would have been great
for me if somebody was a high income
earner when I got when I got unemployed
but I also think it's important because
if you can get somebody doing regular un
um part-time work then that's how you
get your foot in the door a lot of times
to getting a job and that was one of my
thinkings like when I was doing
substitute teaching teaching one of the
full-time teachers that's how he got
into teaching at that school district is
because he had been a substitute for the
whole year working essentially as a
full-time substitute but he started the
process by losing his job and said well
I'm going to do substitute teaching
discovered he liked it was a good fit
with the school they hired him on the
next year and so I think if there's a
disincentive to work because you are you
you work till you get to that 30% and
then you have no incentive to work
anymore then you're going to miss out on
some of these people who a could help us
with the labor CR crunch that we're
currently dealing with and B get their
foot in the door to an employer that
they like wow I never knew I was going
to like being a teacher like in that
example I just told you about and uh
This Is A New Path a new career path for
me and hopefully they'll get out of the
unemployment role a little bit faster um
so that's sort of the logic that's my
story um I recognized that and I spoke
with the Labor uh Security Commission
about this bill before writing it and
and we both acknowledge that it's really
hard to model how this is going to
impact the employment trust fund the the
assumptions are the key here and so if
you operate under the assumption that
more people will work beyond the 30%
then that's actually a good thing
because we're going to have more people
earning money which would continue to
drive down the amount that we're paying
out um if you under if you operate under
the assumption that people don't really
react to that 30% then then maybe it
would be a bad thing it really just
depends in terms from the the balance of
the trust fund it's really depends on
the Assumption and I don't think we
really know until we actually try it but
I hope that you'll consider this bill I
think it's a good idea happen to take
questions but I'd leave you with the
idea that I think we can it shouldn't be
that controversial that creating an
incentive to get more people working is
generally a good thing and it's going to
help those people as well because if if
you're somebody like myself who was
replacing maybe 8% of my previous income
getting some unemployment in addition to
be able to work and and get a little bit
more than what my unemployment would
have been is probably uh good for the
the person on unemployment as well so
with that I'll take any questions all
right thank you are there
questions representative
avani thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative solivan um it's on
line 16 to 17 instead of just crossing
out all wages and earnings why don't we
just put
40% in there and be done
why was why why are we deleting other
lines words prior to and prior after so
yeah so the stuff that's deleted on top
are you talking about the amendment okay
yeah so that's just the the what's
deleted is the current language we need
to replace the current language with the
bolded
40% if I may clarify your
question I I think what you're trying to
say is it's a it's it's 30% of one thing
but 40% of something entirely different
the 30% is a cap and the 40% is of
whatever you discount to what you so
maybe you can explain that better so
right now if you make 30% of whatever
your unemployment benefit is then you
get to keep all that money without
impacting your unemployment benefit if
you go to 31% that 1% gets deducted off
of whatever your unemployment benefit is
so there's zero incentive to ever work
part-time to the point that you would
get above 30% of whatever your
unemployment benefits is this change
would say anything you earn from the
very beginning we will take 40% of
whatever deduct 40% of whatever your
earnings were in a given week from your
unemployment benefits so if you're
making
$300 and under the current system you
could earn just under 100 bucks before
it starts deducting from your benefits
if if you in that same analysis or that
same scenario if you're making $300 and
you earn $100 they would deduct $40 from
your unemployment benefits whereas in
the current system nothing would be
deducted for that first 30% does that
make
sense it makes sense to me okay okay let
let me do it let's do just easier even
though these numbers don't apply to the
New Hampshire system let's assume you're
getting $1,000 a week in unemployment
benefits for easier math you could earn
$300 working part-time and have it not
impact your unemployment
benefits if you earned
$400 then $100 would be deducted because
you get to keep the 30% of whatever your
your your weekly earnings are under this
system if you were earning $1,000 and
then we took and and then you earned
$300 working part-time we would take off
$120 off of your unemployment benefits
so there's an incentive to work if if
sense so the change is there's no hard
cap but also this partial deduction for
the money that you've earned working
part-time starts from the first
dollar so it's a it's two changes at
once I understand
it uh representative
Sullivan is it is it accurate
that currently it's 30% of the benefit
and you're proposing 40% of
earnings yes um I've only changed it to
to to the
wages but the so that was one of the
things that was I I think I fixed it
with the amendment and if I didn't then
and that's like the sticking point then
I I guess you guys would be wiser than I
am how how to address that but I think I
fixed it with the amendment by just
changing uh the wages part
followup follow up the sentence
structure in that part of the bill is
um it it's it's I had to read it about
10 times to try to figure out what it
meant um and I still wasn't sure um so I
basically I I think perhaps if we could
work in this sentence structure and come
up with a clearer way of stating your
intent um that that might help but uh it
just there's a one too many um
prepositional phrases in
there
questions uh representative infantine if
question
two things number one I think was your
question uh Brian I've already had
discussion with the Department they're
going to provide some clarity to it uh
second thing is uh it's very this is
very simple you have a u Act take effect
60 days after its passage my only
question is would you be amendable to
maybe being on a quarterly basis or
whatever the next quarter is going to be
because I think it will help with the
with the Department you know how they do
things on their quarters and other
things would you have any issue if it
was yeah no I think that's that's
totally I think that was just sort of
the default that's put in there so um
whatever is makes it easier for them to
implement if it gets passed then yeah
and if they have ideas of how to better
language I think the the gist of what
I'm trying to do is clear to hopefully
the majority of the people in here um if
if you're supportive of that then
clarifying language I'm that's fine my
think further questions representative
Schulz and if you don't know the answer
to this I can save it but um from when I
was last unemployed I remember one of
the questions to screen whether or not
you're eligible at least it used to be
um you know basically have you been
offered a
job that you're not taking and the
implication I don't know if I'm wording
it exactly the way it was but the
implication was really that you can't
turn down these
shortterm gigs
potentially um do you know the screen
I'm certainly not the expert on it I
know the department will be more
informed than I am but when I was on
unemployment last year that was not how
I interpreted those things because I had
a job that was making well over six
figures taking a job at Walmart or
something like that I don't think is
considered a suitable change so think if
you're able to show that your job was up
here and now you're offered a minimum
wage job I don't think you're required
to take that that was how it was
explained to me anyways thank you
further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony gav back over to
you yes um you are not required to take
something if it does meet a certain
percentage of your previous job and and
whatever um you I just want to make sure
you have have the the pink card from the
last hearing from U Mr got Le and then
you have that one from representative
solivan right there okay um commissioner
lavs assist commissioner labers labers
lavers I'm sorry Richard I rick rich I
apologies You' think after all these
years I'd know how to say it correctly
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
actually pay attention to how you
introduce yourself and I'm going to try
to put it to memory
here I think I pronounce every single
balanced uh thank you Mr chairman so for
the record Richard uh lavers lers I
respond to
both a Deputy Commissioner with
Employment Security um I've handed
around some just some written testimony
with regard to um uh some of the issues
that were addressed in the original bill
I haven't I haven't seen the amended
version that was just discussed but um
as I understand it thank you
representative um so a lot of the
comments that I was planning on making
were with regard to the changes to
deductible earnings um but it looks like
there are no proposed changes to
deductible earnings uh which from the
Department's perspective is good uh
because there was there was some concern
around that and and how it would be
applied compared to how New Hampshire
currently treats separation payments
other types of payments that are
received by an individual when they lose
their employment um and how those
currently apply an impact when you can
start receiving your your your your
temporary wage replacement from the
unemployment program so I'll I won't go
into any of that material um I'll stay
focused on the disregard portion of it
which um is the provision that is um
sought to be changed so uh New Hampshire
like um um every other state in the the
country and I can provide you with a
chart on this um has a disregard for how
much an individual is allowed to earn in
part-time employment while collecting
unemployment benefits before those
earnings start to impact or reduce their
unemployment benefit so New Hampshire
sets it as a percentage of your weekly
benefit amount I think it was uh
described very well um before so an IND
an individual is allowed to have
part-time employment you can't be full
you can't be working full-time uh the
federal government would not consider a
state's law that allowed that to be in
Conformity and compliance with Federal
requirements so you can have part-time
employment um and then New Hampshire
allows you to earn 30% of your weekly
benefit amount uh without any impact on
your weekly benefit amount so for that
uh going back to that um average weekly
benefit amount of around
$350 um so New Hampshire allows you to
have part-time earnings of about 15
$1 or 30% without any reduction uh to
your 350 now the dollars above that 30%
they start to impact your weekly benefit
amount so you keep your earnings you
know we're not doing anything with the
earnings it's the weekly benefit amount
that gets reduced dollar for dooll for
any earnings in excess of 30% of your
weekly benefit amount so again that that
average weekly benefit amount uh fer at
350 anything they're earning above 115
or thereabouts my math isn't perfect U
my father was my high school Kel teacher
so we can blame him um but anything
above that 115 is going to reduce your
your unemployment benefit um so each
state has some has a similar mechanism
um when we look um to our our neighbor
to the east in Maine um they don't set a
percentage they set a flat dollar amount
so in Maine you're allowed to keep the
first $100 earnings and then anything
above that is a reduction against your
unemployment benefit Massachusetts
allows you to earn I think a quarter of
your weekly benefit amount but you can't
exceed your the average weekly benefit
the average weekly wage in the state for
the prior year it's a little bit more
complicated uh than how we do it but
each state has a similar
mechanism um but the the way the
mechanism currently works again it's
it's 30% and that 30% is of your of your
weekly unemployment benefit so it's not
of your earnings it's of your
unemployment benefit so that first
$115 on that example that person keeps
that
$115 without any impact to their $350
weekly unemployment benefit um what I am
understanding The Proposal would do is
it would it would increase the 30 to
40% it would be 40% of your earnings and
it would be on the first dollar earned
so um right now you you don't have any
impact on the first dollar earned so um
a an individual who um has low part-time
earnings while they're collecting
unemployment um would see no impact to
their unemployment benefit if we were to
change that into reduce their benefit
with the first dollar earned then there
would be an impact on their unemployment
benefit with that first dollar earned so
that would be a um significant change in
how this 30% disregard is currently uh
constructed um in New Hampshire
um with regard to the um the suitable
work conversation so um an individual is
required to accept suitable employment
so you're not you're not required to
accept all employment I thought the
example um uh from the the prior speaker
was excellent where if you were earning
six figures and offered a a uh a job at
Walmart greeting individuals that's not
going to necessarily consider be
suitable employment for you um we look
at what you earned in your prior
employment we look at um what your
commuting pattern was in your prior
employment we look at what the commute
would be required in the job that's
being offered we look at what your
obligations at home are um you know what
shifts are you available for because of
uh perhaps you have to take care of kids
or or an adult in the house all of that
is considered when looking at whether or
not a job that is offered to you is
considered suitable um so if it is
suitable and you don't accept it um that
would uh disqualify you for benefits um
for that week if it is determined to be
not suitable um then you're going to get
paid your benefits for that week because
the job that was offered was not
considered suitable so that's an anal
that's an analysis we do um as part of
it can come up in a variety of ways it
could be the individual um informing the
department of that when they're filing
their weekly claim it could be an
employer calling in and saying hey I
keep on offering people jobs and they
they keep on uh not taking them and
telling me that they want to continue to
collect unemployment benefits and I
don't think that's right can you look at
this for me um so we we look at it in a
variety of ways um but you're required
to accept suitable employment and
suitable employment is different based
upon your circumstances and we look at
each and every one on a case-by Case
basis um and um with that I'll I'll turn
it over um back to the committee all
right I'm going to do something a little
unorthodox if you might to stay there
for a second because I'm I'm a little
confused my vice chairman and I are
having a little discussion here
representative Sullivan it is your
intent to try to allow an individual to
earn more
money um on a side
job before it impacts their unemployment
correct sort of my intent is to
encourage people to work more so right
now when we hit that 30% cut off you're
actually worse off if you work that
extra dollar because some taxes are
taking out of that extra dollar so if we
could encourage people to work because
the 40% just it's always 40% whether you
go to 50% of your potential earnings
it's 40% of that or whatever of your
weekly earnings so my intent is to
encourage people to work past the point
of making 30% of your weekly payment all
right understood thank you I just want
to make sure so um rich and I had a
conversation earlier in the week about
this um had a neighbor he was making a
example 100 beans a week on his regular
job he was making 25 beans a week
working for the
church he lost his
job and he went to get unemployment
which is the max of the
427 but then he was going to get cut on
some of that 427 because of the the
money he made on the weekends doing some
stuff for the church and I thought to
myself how stupid is that he had two
sets of incomes he was making 100 beans
here and 25 beans here and he's still
making the 25 beans because he still has
that job how many people have part-time
jobs the first four years of my life I
had two jobs you know um and or of my
business or life um so why why would I
want to hurt somebody by taking away
their 25 beans and and and and yet on
the other hand I can say okay well you
don't want someone kind of not having
that second job getting a second job and
and getting the other there's got to be
a better way because I don't like that
it affects the person that is willingly
working two jobs to to make ends meet or
to have things better for themselves yet
they lose their bigger job and they get
nixed for it and I think this would sort
of address that You' still you'd get
some deducted but it wouldn't really
hurt you too much versus Under the
current system if that well that with
your math the 25 beans wouldn't be
impacted but if you were earning 35
beans it certainly would now
also Mr LS and I talk about the fact
that the wording may
be backwards it may hurt more than
you're
helping did I miss that in our earlier
conversation
um well the the wording and um the the
removal of the the current language in
excess of and then the comparison being
against your your weekly unemployment
benefit um that's the wording that we
had talked about previously so and I
think that's it's intentional um but um
the sponsors looking at changing that
percentage and increasing it but also it
being being a percentage of a of a it's
a different denominator right um so
looking at it being a percentage of your
earnings rather than the percentage of
your weekly unemployment benefit which
is how it it currently is
structured so go ahead also this is not
a novel idea this is the system that
Vermont uses as well uh and other other
states as well but I just looked at the
three around us so it's not like I
created this on my own
all right representat I appreciate it if
you would uh step back and uh appreciate
you you you doing what you just did with
these guys now I have questions of my
committee uh one Brian followed by the
other Brian because you you had that
first seaworth by
Sullivan um I won't ask this as a
question to the previous one um maybe
he'll not have you heard uh phrase uh as
um benefits Cliff where um when people
get to a certain point of the benefits
and and since you're nodding I'll ask
the question of you people getting to a
certain point of their
benefits earning another dollar they
lose a dollar or more from the benefits
so there's zero incentive to cross that
line
and I see you nod yes
maybe um yeah I'm quite familiar with
the the whole benefit Cliff issue the um
uh if you if you Google benefit Cliff
New Hampshire the first link that comes
up is a report that was done a few years
ago by a a firm called EC consult they
teamed up with the national Center for
Children in poverty and did a a report
looking at all sorts of benefit payments
in New Hampshire looking at tanif and
snap and Medicaid housing vouchers um uh
fuel assistance and unemployment
benefits um it was a report that was
done um at the behest of Health and
Human Services and employment security
um if you haven't looked at I would i'
highly suggest it it actually does a a
community by community um analysis of
benefit cliffs in your community based
upon the recipiency rates of residents
of that town or or city and what they're
receiving from different um uh
government support programs uh that that
report is currently being updated uh by
econsult through some money that the the
legislature provided to Health and Human
Services in the the last budget um so
the the characterization of this
disregard as a benefit Cliff um
that that that is correct um any way
that it is applied at whatever
percentage it could it in is in some
ways uh functioning similar to a a type
of benefit Cliff what we have to
remember is that we can't allow uh
individuals to have uh full-time
earnings um full-time employment and
earnings from full-time employment and
still be eligible for an unemployment
benefit so that's kind of the ceiling
that we have to stay under in order to
maintain compliance with the feds um but
as the the sponsor had indicated and and
he had suggested this um the amendment
is similar to what Vermont does I told
you what what Maine does each state has
something a little bit different and I
I'll provide you that chart um you'll
get a headache from looking at it but
I'll provide that to you you can see um
how complicated and how simple some of
the states are I think New Hampshire's
probably one of the has a more of a
simple way of disregarding arding Maine
as a simple way of disregarding um and
uh some of the other states are much
more complicated follow thank you and
thank you for that information I
definitely will take a look at that
report my followup is a question because
I think you're better at math than I am
so you talked about what happens at the
low end if someone is is already covered
by that 30% and what they might
lose I'm wondering if there's an issue
at the high end so someone has part-time
employment but it's they they're paid
substantially
and without there being any kind of cap
where you say you're earning so much
through part-time that you don't need
these unemployment benefits before does
this formula have like kind of a runaway
at the top end or am I not doing the
math right well you you're allowed to
earn more um if your weekly benefit
amount is more the way it currently is
applied right so if you're at the max if
you're you're getting that 427 you're
allowed to earn 30% of 427 before it has
any impact on your weekly benefit amount
so you get up to you get up to around
550 uh 550 of thereabouts um and what
your your net take-home can be between
your part-time earnings and your
unemployment benefit before there's any
reduction and then when you get above
that so you can you can have 130% of
your weekly benefit amount right now
okay um and then anything above that is
then results in that dollar for dooll um
reduction to your weekly unemployment
benefit so and that I understand if we
went to this new formula where your
reduction
was 40 cents on every dollar but
absolutely no cap I'm wondering where
eventually
that you
you and and that's where I can't do the
math very well yeah
entire payment but does that get I mean
isn't isn't that point a pretty high
amount of earnings from your part-time
job before that you're still getting
some unemployment as a supplement for it
yeah and we can we can look at that and
and do some of that math for you know if
it's applied at 40% of the earnings um
before you're going to have any
reduction to your weekly benefit amount
can see some scenarios for what that net
take home is going to be and where
you're going to zero out on your on your
weekly benefit amount we can certainly
look I mean I think you you want to stay
away from obviously um providing a
scenario where an individual um well I
can't say this it's you're the ones who
make this decision but at some point you
don't want to create um for for someone
that is separated from full-time
employment and U Mr Summers might
disagree with me from the hospitality
industry if he's still here um but you
want to encourage them back to full-time
employment M um right you don't want to
cause an exhaustion issue with someone
is taking that 427 to the full extent
that they can um and combining that with
part-time earnings um and run that out
the 26 weeks we want people back to
full-time employment for those that were
separated from full-time employment
that's what the that's what the economy
needs thank you that's exactly what I
was trying to get at thanks other
representative Brian thank you um as I
understand this um you will continue
receiving a benefit um for part-time
employment
until um 40% of your earnings is equal
that I can comment and tell you how the
current system works um but you guys get
to make the decision whether or not
that's the right policy okay I'm just
I'm I'm searching for the down I mean
it's different it's different because as
you pointed out um 40% of your first
dollar of part-time employment is uh
deducted from your benefit it's also uh
different because you can exceed the 30%
and still continue getting a benefit so
you'll get a benefit until your um uh
your earnings are equal to or greater
than your your um weekly benefit um
which I'm I'm assuming 427 but um could
be less than that if if the
circumstances are such okay thank you
yeah so that impact is is different you
know with the The Proposal the the
impact is different on that person
who has um less part-time employment
right because right now perhaps they're
not having any impact on their
unemployment benefit but I think in what
I heard from the sponsor was he wants to
incentivize more more work more more
part-time employment and so as you get
up into higher earnings that's where you
would have a a a positive impact
um from from this bill and you'd be and
you'd be holding on to more of it but
your first 40 um you know your first
dollar 40 cents of that would reduce
your B that oh and and essentially you
eliminate the
cliff there there's there's no Cliff you
continue getting a benefit um far uh
further into your part-time
earnings you change the cliff I don't
think you eliminate it but the cliff now
I think you always have a cliff would be
$427
you you you change the cliff but anytime
you're you're um anytime there's a
disregard I think you're creating some
Cliff
right thank you Mr chair so earlier my
question actually isn't the same as what
the bill addresses at all I think um
this addresses part-time and other
scenarios but what about you said that
the federal law
required um if someone obviously has a
full-time job that um isn't what is
addressed with this bill but what about
if it's a short-term gig for example
when I this happened to me in uh
2011 um I had a job that lasted just a
month after I'd been unemployed and you
know was relatively in my career
whatever but when I went back on
unemployment because I didn't have
another job lined up it put me into a
different quarter and it refigured
everything and it was a significant ding
than other than if I had stayed and not
taken that job um there was that's a
different kind of
penalty is that something that can be
addressed as well potentially is a
similar I hope people understand what
I'm saying it I know you get it
um and so I think with you with the um
the short-term employment representative
that you had taken um was that taken
after you were you were separated from a
another job and for which you were
receiving unemployment benefits for and
then I took a short-term gig that lasted
about a month um and had a set ending
date when I took that job so it was a
full-time job for a month but that was
considered regular employment at that
point and I was considered at the time
to not be employed anymore so then when
I went back on unemployment having not
lined it was a tough year 2011 um you
know having not lined up a job because
it put me into the next quarter for
redetermination it was a new claim this
is for to help explain it to folks it's
a it was a brand new claim even though I
knew going into that job yeah does that
make sense yeah so the way that ways
significant reduction in the amount of
of weekly benefits that I could receive
after that point it would have been
better actually in terms of the
incentives it would have been better for
me
financially given that it still took me
a while to get a job in my career in my
field um that was long term um to have
not taken the month-long job even though
it was the right thing to do for me
personally psychologically and
everything else um is that something
that could be addressed in a in
something like this bill and perhaps as
an addition to this bill if that is
something that could be changed if we
wanted
to um so this bill doesn't address that
but you
know speaking from experience the the
timing of our unemployment is never good
right um and what you're describing is
how the current weekly benefit amount is
calculated so when we had looked at the
the chart that's proposed to be changed
by representative McKenzie um the your
weekly benefit amount is determined by
your earnings in the first four of the
most recently completed five calendar
quarters okay and what the department
currently does so if you do not have um
um minimum adequate earnings in the
first four of the most recently
completed five calendar quarters we will
look at the most recent four completed
calendar quarters so if you didn't have
2,800 bucks in the first four um and 14
in in uh each and of two separate
quarters we will look to what we call an
alternative base period and we'll look
at the the most recent four completed
quarters but you're always looking at
four completed quarters in order to
determine what that weekly benefit
amount is going to be and if you are in
a situation where you um are unemployed
through no fault of your own um after a
short stint of employment um that prior
four quarters like you described might
not be uh very good in terms of what
your total earnings were but that's how
we determine it right now it's your
total earnings and covered employment W2
employment your total earnings in the
first four of the most recently
completed five calendar quarters so if
you wanted to change that it would have
to be uh changing the the way in which
the base period is used and how um it
then correlates to a weekly benefit
amount follow
up thank you um so would we knowing that
there's a federal implication
potentially
could we um Implement a freeze KN if
someone accepted a short-term job that
was good in their field and the pay blah
blah blah to avoid this sort of penalty
in the way that these things are
determined by the quarters could we put
a freeze on it if someone took a job
knowing it had a set in date so you know
similar to my experience if someone took
a
month-long job that they knew was going
to end on the 31st day
would we legally be allowed as a state
to address that um to avoid the sort of
penalty that would come in that scenario
because it is very similar it's
basically deinen diviz work at a time we
you know it's so many for so many
reasons better to have even a month-long
gig is
better can't are we to your
understanding of how it is federally
could we put a freeze on that
unemployment so that someone isn't
penalized based on the way the
quarters you um with every proposal we
we submitted to the US Department of
Labor for their review to see if it's in
compliance and Conformity with with
Federal requirements um so I can't
speculate as to what they would say um
you could certainly propose something um
the the other impacts of changing the
base period so right now if I if you're
in a short-term employment that's less
than 12 weeks and your and you're
separated through no fault of your own
and you qualify for unemployment the
benefits paid out to you are not uh
counted against that employer's
experience okay um if it's above 12
weeks they are so what could happen here
is because in the usual situation the
benefits paid out are going to be
counted against the experience of your
most recent employer in most instances
that's your separating employer corre
right so New Hampshire is a is a most
recent employer M State okay um and so
it's that employer's experience that
takes a negative hit as a result of
those benefits being paid out if now
you're going to move your your um
separation further into the future and
I'm going to be going further back to um
have a negative impact on the experience
of a of a of an employer from further
back in history that employer might
might cry foul because they're saying
wait a minute I didn't have anything to
do with that subsequent loss of
employment but yet my experience is
being negatively impacted by it um what
what we do in some situations you know
in our statute we have a bunch of
voluntary quit exclusions right where
you can quit employment for certain
reasons like a domestic violence
situation or um with certain types of
non-work related um injuries um we don't
charge the most recent employer for
those benefits they get charged against
the fund so they get shared by all
employers um it's still a burden on the
fund um but we don't hit the experience
of that employer but if you go if you if
you're going to move the the uh base
period around you're going to have that
issue where an employer is going to be
hit for benefits where they had nothing
them
thank you it's actually not even a
question I was just I think
representative seaworth was doing it too
we just did the math out and so if it's
40% of uh the total made until it
basically evens itself out it seems like
it'll be roughly
1,070 a week for a part-time job before
your benefits in essence get erased
that's kind of I just want to say that
because we're kind of talking about that
for second but if my Math's right that's
be uh thank you Mr chair I also have a
question for you but let me ask Mr
labers first uh what if we just simply
raise the Rait from 30 to 40% would that
help quite a few
people um well yet you'd be able to to
hold on to more of your earnings uh well
you'd be able to your your net take-home
would be more right so anytime you're
increasing that 30% disregard now you'll
be able to earn more before it reduces
your unemployment benefit and when you
when you combine those part-time
earnings and your your weekly
unemployment benefit you're going to be
you know at the end of the week you're
going to have more than you would under
the current 30% system and you're still
interested in finding work more work
because this isn't quite enough
either I would think so yes Mr chair um
were any of those 125 beans magic beans
because that could change the whole
equation
uh thank you uh thank you for taking my
question so this should be a simple one
uh there's varying definitions of
fulltime depending on industry what's
the def what is it 40 hours for this no
it is not it's uh 37 and a half 37 and a
half thank you anything under 37 and
half is considered parttime can I do a
followup yes um what is uh the what is
typical for part-time work in New
Hampshire um I'm unable to answer that
because what we receive from uh
employers on a quarterly basis does not
include that information so we have very
minimal uh tax and wage reports in terms
of the content so an employer only
reports um your last name first initial
your social and the total wages paid
during that quarter I don't know if it's
part-time full-time I don't know know
whether um that worker is male female I
don't know how many hours they worked um
so a lot that we don't know um you're
able to get some of that through Bureau
labor statistic survey data but it's not
directly from the administrative records
you thank you Mr chairman thank you
again uh Deputy Commissioner um on line
11 we're looking to remove um the
definition of wages and earnings and
we also under line eight as say earnings
from self-employment so anybody that has
a business has earnings we don't make
wages um we be moving that allow people
to have become self-employed no longer
report their earnings and still claim um
unemployment full unemployment
benefits um I'm I'm not sure what the
what the intent is of that particular
change in in this amended version the
the initial the the original version
actually struck um self-employment from
being considered uh for the earnings
from self-employment and the department
would have had major concerns with that
because um you would have been
essentially allowing an individual to
have unlimited self-employment earnings
and still collect their full
unemployment benefit I don't think
that's um the intent of the the
unemployment program that provides
temporary partial wage replacement thank
you and a quick followup Mr
chairman
um if the bill on line 17 and 18 goes
through as written uh would it be
incentivize employeers to get rid of
their layoff or fire their full-time
employees put them on unemployment
benefits and then rehire them as
part-time
employees um well we have a program that
does that um so employers right now if
they're looking at like a just a a
temporary work reduction um where they
can they can participate in our work
share program um which is much more
beneficial for them rather than um going
through the actual layoff and then bring
people back part-time um so we have a
program that incentivizes employers to
to reduce the amount of uh if they need
to reduce the amount of hours people can
collect a portion of their unemployment
benefit the employer has to continue to
provide them with Benefits um to the
extent they did previously um but we we
encourage employers into that program
rather than doing um the scenario that
you just described thank you and one
final one um and the final one uh Deputy
Commissioner is um if there is 40%
incentive um and we have the duration
increase in the trust fund which means
we'll lower the value which increase
taxes on the employers would that be a
reasonable
assumption um yeah I think any any um
change to that 30% disregard is going to
is going to result in some additional
benefits being paid out uh from the the
trust fund we had described and I won't
go through it again but we had described
why that's very difficult to
with any degree of accuracy in
forecasting out that impact um in the
language that we included in the fiscal
note but there would be an impact right
you're um similar to the other changes
which have been withdrawn where we where
we weren't going to consider all all
different types of Separation payments
as deductible and delaying your receipt
of unemployment benefits if you increase
your disregard the 30% disregard it's
going to accelerate uh the payment of
benefits you're going to um you're going
to hit more over that duration than you
otherwise would have you're capped out
you have you have a maximum amount that
you can get which is your weekly benefit
amount multiplied by 26 so for that 427
person they're they're maxing out at
about 11 Grand just just over um so you
might be hitting that full maximum
benefit sooner or a higher amount sooner
um if you know we're we're making
changes to the current disregard thank
you thank you Mr
chairman
thank you Mr chair uh how many chucks
with a wood chuck no no
um looking at the if you're if you're
doing some parttime work and that's say
W2 work is that is that not paying into
the trust fund no it is no very very
good point um
all all W2 earnings are required to be
reported um or wages are required to be
reported by that employer for the
quarter in which they are paid whether
or not um so if
I'm uh say I have multiple jobs okay I'm
going to be U I'm going to have multiple
$14,000 taxable wage bases right so um
depending on when I hit my $144,000
taxable wage base per job is determined
whether or not any of those earnings are
taxable so the earnings still have to be
reported the employer still has to pay
at their tax rate on the first 14,000 in
annual earnings um so depending on what
I've how much I've worked and how much
I've earned the dollars that you're
talking about might be dollars that are
no longer taxable because we already hit
you
sure
for everybody waiting for the next bill
we kind of ran over on the previous bill
so
we'll probably wait another five minutes
to people who are get still getting food
start
minute folks any committee members that
are here please take your
seats should I know that looks good
would me to take
seat right right where you are take it
home take it to the bank oh my gosh
these are nice seats can we buy these at
I do I have a pink card I have a pink
card
johon we we have the sponsor we have the
is I think we're almost in his district
are we in your District No we're in my
district I am opening the hearing on
House Bill
1375 sorry Eric Gallagher Gallagher
thank you representative Gallagher
is recognized
to introduce his
bill hi thank you welcome to the labor
committee hi um so for the record I'm
representative Eric Gallagher
representing Marc County District 20
that's conquered w six which is down the
street that ways a little um so and I'm
here to
introduce HB 1375 relative to Severance
agreements requiring employees to
broadly wave labor law
rights
um so
basically where this bill came from was
um I was talking with constituents about
their workplaces and various problems
they had with it and
um so some of them told me some of their
problems and um said oh man that sounds
bad why didn't you raise a big stink
about it and to which they told me oh
well I don't think I could have because
I had a non I had to sign a
non-disparagement
agreement when um I left
so uh
basically yeah this this bill is meant
to address cases like that I think
people should be able to talk freely
about um their
experiences working somewhere after they
leave it so people can get a good idea
about what conditions are like there um
and have the information necessary to um
decide whether they might want
to uh do business there themselves um so
yeah and I think um
since since it's up to the government to
enforce these non-disparagement
Clauses in
um I I I think that this could even be
seen as a freedom of speech issue um
since by enforcing a non-disparagement
clause you'd be inhibiting the employees
freedom of speech um
and so
um also
[Music]
um what what to address the criticism
well don't you voluntarily enter into
contracts or something the whole point
of leaving somewhere is that you don't
want to do business with them anymore um
so yeah I mean if you know you're
basically stuck without a real Choice
there when you want to leave somewhere
so uh I I think
that that that kind of distinguishes
severance agreements from nor normal
contracts
um so yeah I I basically just asked OS
to draft me a bill
um about
um about um yeah non-disparagement
agreements it
in uh Severance packages and uh this is
the language that they drafted for me
um so um yeah that's the bill and I'll
take questions
out representative Schultz thank you
thank you Mr thank you Mr chair um to
play Devil's
Advocate why not steer folks who are
frustrated with their former workplace
to the anonymous sites like glass door I
don't know if you've heard of glass door
yeah um
well yeah you um I meant to mention that
in my testimony but uh forgot to get
around to it um I I think this
helps um remove kind of some of the
uncertainity around posting to places
like glass door you know as you
mentioned they're Anonymous and the
reason people post there anonymously is
out of fear of Retribution for finding
out that they might be violating a
non-disparagement agreement and I think
people should be able to do so openly
with their own names attached to it um
you know that to kind of and that that
would help give their claims greater
Credence If people could see oh um this
is from someone who actually worked
there um so yeah I I I think um yeah
it's good that sites that glass store
exist and um this bill should be helpful
for
them repr
Sullivan thank
you um having spent um quite a few years
in labor relations um I was actually
involved in quite a few Severance
agreements um and these sever agreements
first of all usually paid someone some
money to go away um and um usually there
would be a
um an agreement for both parties not to
um speak uh unkindly about the other um
I and from my experience if that wasn't
part of the agreement there would be no
agreement there'd be no severance and
anyone who wants to can simply quit uh
go away and say anything they
want um can you see how that could be a
uh a detriment for someone who wants a
severance
agreement
um I I mean I I
think I I think yeah um if if somebody
doesn't want to talk then they should
have an option to take the agreement
instead but I also do think that people
who do want to talk should also have the
option to talk and right now um many
people don't seem to um think that they
that represent
balani thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative gallager so the flip side
of this should the employer be able to
disparage or an
employee
um I mean yeah I generally support I you
know I generally support more speech
rather than less um
I um I mean I think there is kind of a
power differential there um in terms of
an employees life will be a lot more
ruined if they're disparaged than um say
an employers would um
um yeah I think um you know I I
would want to maintain the uh status quo
with um existing labor law um
with what the uh Federal nlrb enforces
regards oh go ahead representative stop
thank you thank you for taking my
question um can I um ask um in these
situations um what kind of Leverage does
the employer hold over the employee to
make them sign these Severance
agreements do they withhold wages is
there um um is there some reason that
people feel like they must sign these
agreements when they separate from a
company thank you
um yeah I mean this is kind of one of
the things people wouldn't tell me
because of um the Clauses in question so
there's a little bit of a boot strap's
Paradox there but I I do think it comes
um
uh yeah B Just the whole General um
employer employee relationship in
general where you know employers are
referred to as the bosses and people
assume that orders that bosses give are
valid and um it's just kind of how
representative stab it would be illegal
in New Hampshire to withhold wages uh
pending a a a uh you know you do the
wages by the end of the week or within
three business days or whatever a lot of
the other things are usually for
severances and and you know long-term
parachutes and things like that uh rev
Gallagher um one of the great things
about the New Hampshire legislature is a
representative like yourself can talk to
someone down the street and find out
about a problem and then submit a bill
uh which you you've done here do you
recall specifically at all what the
circumstance was with that constituent
you spoke with um it was
uh well so it was someone uh who I was
trying to figure out how um there uh it
was a teacher who was in negotiations
with their school board
um and I was trying to figure out more
about how
um how their negotiations went and um
the reason they told me that they
couldn't tell me more um about what
happened was because um of a
non-disparagement agreement that they'd
signed when they
left okay thank
representative seeing none thank you
very much for testifying thanks for
Bel next is David ju from the
seat that's an inside joke is uh he
wanted to know if he could bring as I as
I'm walking here he wanted to know if he
could bring a bottle of water and the
security guard said well it's up to the
chairman so we had to negotiate a little
bit thank you Mr chair for completely
throwing me under the
bus um for the record my name is Dave
juv I'm a senior vice president with the
business and industry
Association uh we serve as New
Hampshire's Statewide Chamber of
Commerce we have approximately 400
employer members with over 100,000
Granite State Employees I'm here uh in
opposition to this bill um I thought
several uh Representatives on the
committee uh have already asked some
pretty good questions um I do want to
let the committee know that issues like
this are um already a part of federal
labor relations acts that stipulate uh
what can and cannot be a part of a um
Severance
agreement uh so in in one sense I think
this would be preempted by federal law
this bill does go beyond what the
federal law is so um I'm not sure that's
a good
thing um the reality is that that um
when you're considering legislation I
would hope one of the first things you
ask is is there a problem here that
needs to be corrected and I am certain
that there may be uh one or several
individ uals who may have felt grieved
about the parameters of the severance
agreement that they agreed to that they
signed and agreed to um represent
Sullivan was absolutely correct in the
event of a severance agreement which by
the way is not generally initiated by
the employee it's generally initiated by
the employer because there's a situation
that needs to be remedied and uh it
needs to be remedied in such a way that
it there's not
not publicly firing the individual
there's a thousand different reasons why
Severance agreements happen but one
thing they all have in common is that
it's a negotiation between the employee
and the employer uh the employer
generally um will make it worth the
individuals um consideration to agree to
the agreement but there's no obligation
for that individual to agree to to it so
I find this uh Bill unnecessary I think
it could lead to a Pandora's box of all
kinds of um unintended consequences and
I would ask the committee to uh itl it
I'm happy to answer any questions Mr
chair and so far I have not spilled the
water just as long as we know that we'll
to take some questions are there any
questions for Mr
juet
Michael
representative kahill since you brought
it up um I do not have a severance
agreement Beyond uh with my employer
beyond that I'm retiring October 31st so
uh this will be my last session
oh see that's why I give you a hard time
because it's your last session if
there's no other questions for Mrs ju
testifying Brendan flare New Hampshire
Association of counties you are the next
contestant on labor is right all right I
do have a letter to the association
can is everyone comfortable temperature-
wise just checking the other guys down
there because I know I was King when I
first walked in after I went to the
bathroom I was like wow it's stuffy in
here yeah I felt that way all the
morning well good afternoon uh Mr
chairman and members of the committee
thank you my name is Brendan flarey I'm
here today um for the New Hampshire
Association of counties and the
association is opposed to the uh to
House Bill 1375 it really follows Mr
jv's testimony um as I said they're
oppos Association of counties is opposed
on the rounds that uh the bill prohibits
employees from entering a severance
agreement but there's currently nothing
that compels employees to enter these
agreements um and employees and
employers uh should have the ability to
freely enter any agreement um that they
choose and this bill restricts the uh
their ability to do that um that's all I
got uh thank you for your time and I'm
happy to take questions but I'm going to
I'm going to take them back to um the
all
right representative seaworth thank you
Mr chairman I'm wondering and if you if
you know the background where um this
kind of agreement
might take place in the county
environment it does it tend to be
associated with labor agreements
or uh I'm going to have to take that
back to the county county administrators
but happy to have them follow up with
seeing no other questions thank you very
much for your testimony I do not have
any additional pink cards is there
anyone else who would like to speak on
1375 all right the hearing is now closed
on 1375 we will reconvene at 2 o' for
the our the next bill
1519 feel free to speak amongst
yourselves
hey uh Tim you know you know where uh M
to trying to work on what we're going to
um well subcommittee is not no the
subcommittee is not going to give us
enough time because we have to have it
out in two weeks but I seriously think
we need to do some things and and I I
know
that
quiet so I assume we must uh be at 2
o'cl by now uh the chairman had to go
and testify before another committee um
so I would let like to get started
opening um the hearing on House Bill
1519 and I would like to recognize the
leus thank you ala alus Hillsboro
um I am not positive that the words of
this bill accurately describe the intent
of this bill three conversations with
the drafting attorney and a redraft
which came out the very last day I'm not
sure it's right but um I don't know
labor I know education so I figured if I
presented to you the intent of the bill
and it needed to be changed I am willing
to do whatever to change it I know it's
your bill but I'm willing to do the leg
work um and get it fixed so my
intent was based on conversation I had
with numerous students and parents who
were frustrated because the either the
kids or well because the kids wanted to
work during what was normally School
hours now some of those kids are seniors
they only are going partial days and
they want to work the rest of that time
some of them are homeschool kids who
work on a who do their homeschool on a
different time frame they may do
afternoons and evenings instead of
mornings and afternoons and they wanted
to be able to go to work during those
what would be normally school hours and
they were told by their employers that
they can't do that because of treny
rules and various other things that they
wouldn't be able to work during the
hours the normal school hours and so I
didn't actually find any rules or laws
that said that they couldn't but
apparently employers think they can't
and so I thought that my intent was just
really to make it very clear that yes if
a child does not have to be in school
during particular hours yes they can
work during those hours so that my
intent was very simple I do not intend
to change any other labor laws or
anything else I just wanted a very clear
statement so that employers would know
yes they could hire these
children thank you for that testimony I
do I don't want to get too into the
technical details of it because of what
you said but I have a couple of maybe
broader ones um first in the first
section uh paragraph 4 did any of your
discussion come up with what New
Hampshire does in terms of the 16 and
under youth is mirror federal
law um
so by removing Federal Provisions from
the state law doesn't make something
legal did did you look into no because I
had said I don't want to change any law
I just want to make the law
clear I didn't want to actually change
working hours and whatever unless you
can tell me that in fact it is illegal
for kids to work during school hours I
was not able to find
that and I guess the other question I
would have along those same lines is it
sounded and this is one I know labor law
but I don't know the truancy laws
and if as you hinted at the issue is
within the treny section of the law did
you look at that as the place that would
education and those laws I do know and
they are just required to be in school
but it doesn't have any hours especially
not for homeschool kids there are no
particular hours that they have to be
there
so yes it doesn't actually violate true
and say as long as the child is not
supposed is not actually supposed to be
hours all right thank you and I I agree
with your statement that I think this
language
is a long way from the intent and
I I don't know how to how to connect
those dots but I mean on that we agree
yes well I'm willing to start over this
was I and I communicated multiple times
this is all I want and this is what I
got and I don't think it's right so with
that are there other members of the
committee with questions representative
stop yeah thank you for taking my
question on lines four and five um it
strikes the language that says that uh
youth under the age of 16 years um it it
says that they should not be allowed to
work more than 3 hours per day on school
days in 23 hours per week on school
weeks and that that language has been
struck is was that your intent that was
not my intent I do not know why it was
struck because I was very specific I
don't want to change any laws okay all
right thank
you further questions representative
kahill thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative lers I I think as far as
the The Homeschool issue I understand
they may have a different schedule but
most employers are more comfortable
working with the calendar and schedule
of the local school district and that
way they I could understand where they
feel apprehensive about someone
saying I my hours are
different uh I I'm not sure would you
believe that that I think this might be
unworkable uh for the employ lawyers
well I was considering I mean what I
would have liked in here was something
verification so that a child could
either bring a note from their school
saying no I'm not required to be in
school during these hours like for a
senior who's working partial day I mean
attending partial day or from the parent
The Homeschool parent saying no we do
our home school these hours not those
hours and so I would be very happy to
see that in here as a verification so
employers wouldn't be put in that
position
follow yeah actually it was it was a
very long time ago but I during my
senior year I also worked uh I only had
morning classes so I worked in the
afternoon and uh and I don't remember
any questions or verification but this
was another state so but perhaps that
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony I do not see any other pink
cards on this bill um so if there was
anybody in the in the audience today did
you get another one I did not no so if
anyone else um wants to speak please
otherwise uh do you wish to ask if we if
we could have the department come up y
thank
you good afternoon Mr chairman and
committee thank you my name is Tracy
McGraw I'm an attorney and legislative
leam for the New Hampshire Department of
Labor and I'm here to answer any
questions you need representative line
Thank you Mr chairman thank you again
miss McGrath for being here um uh
hearing the comments of the uh
representative that brought this forward
um bringing a note to the
employer um would the would the
Department of Labor view that as okay
well he hasn't know he's okay to be here
or would the employer be in violation of
labor law under not the changes but the
current
law
so basically what you would need is
either one an authorization from the
parent and you would need a document
that came from the school a a formalized
document that gave you whatever the
specific schedule was but the issue that
comes into play is how difficult is it
going to be for an employer to have to
keep track of how many employees they
have what their various schedules are to
keep track of one schedule and we have a
lot of communities where people will
travel a little distance to go to work
and I use you know a supermarket chain
let's say where kids are coming from
different school
districts one thing to have a School
District calendar in your personel file
and for that employer to know exactly
what the calendar is versus having not
not only the school district calendar
that shows you what the school district
requires but also then having a separate
document from that school stating that
um this particular student is able or is
is not at work or excuse me is not at
school during this particular time and
then have to keep track of that it opens
the door the concern that the department
has is it opens the door for the
employer to violate
unwittingly and it would be a very
difficult position to put put the
employer in um but as far as an actual
note from a student I don't know that
the department would actually accept
that as verification of what the student
is actually required to attend in school
thank you thank you Mr I'd kind of like
to follow up in a clarification it so
let's and I I understand your point that
most
employers whatever the law is probably
say you know what that is so complicated
don't know whether I'm going to be legal
or not so I'm just going to this is the
simple rule but supposing that a
employer did go through and collecting
they have kids from multiple school
districts so each one they have a
calendar each one they have um a note
from the school itself with class
schedules and they're really keeping
track of that is there anything that
stops them in current law from doing
that way or would the department come
down on them simply
because it's it's
complex well the department can handle
complex and the department knows that
employers can handle complex the
employer has a right to decide whether
they want to handle
complex uh If an employer an employee
came in I'm not even sure who would
actually be the complainant in this
particular situation might be the parent
um but if the employer or the
employee is before the a hearing officer
at the Department of Labor over a
question of whether or not they should
have
worked if you've got that document from
the school not a handwritten document
from Mom Dad or the student if you've
got the document from the school and the
employer is willing to take the extra
time and care to make sure that that
student is not working during times that
he is actually required by his own
personal schedule to work work then as
long as it followed current law which I
know that we're in the process of of
adjusting hopefully or I I know that
there's some bills out there as long as
it's within current law they're not
working past what they're supposed to be
working if it changed to that then we
administer and I guess there's a
followup it seems to me from what you
said is it wouldn't need to change to
that because
there's there's nothing stopping someone
from properly
documenting the schedule and validating
that a 17-year-old is in fact not
required to be anywhere
else it doesn't seem like we need to
make a law that authorizes
that I think what I'd like to do before
I give you a final answer on that is
take a look at the law a little bit more
closely back at my office and I would be
more more than happy to respond to the
entire committee on that because I want
to make sure that I give you accurate
information and compare it to what this
bill is trying to do and see whether or
not there would be an issue of a
violation I I would appreciate that
because I don't know either thank you uh
let's go with representative Granger uh
thank
you is it so this this is an important
question in regards to the homeschoolers
is there anything that currently
prevents a homeschooler from working
during school hours if they're obviously
a homeschooler and they can set their
them and their parents negotiate their
own schooling
hours homeschoolers and and The
Homeschool program is associated with
whatever particular School District that
they're with and they have to follow the
district schedule as far as specifics as
to classes if the district schedule
allows for this kind of um free change
of classes or being out during certain
periods periods the way I had no idea
even
existed um but if if they're able to
take the afternoon off from school and
still get all of their required
classwork in and that is something that
the school accepts or would accept then
that should fit within the same category
so if you're looking at somebody who is
not scheduled to work in the morning or
excuse me not scheduled to go to school
in the morning because they're doing
homeschool in the afternoon it really
has to depend on what the school
district allows as well because they
so my understanding of the intent of the
Prime sponsor if I understood her
correctly is to allow homeschoolers to
work during normal hours because when
you're a
homeschooler uh if you're usually not
beholden to the public school that's
kind of the point is that you don't want
to be doing what the public school is
doing so if the point of the bill is to
allow them the free reign to just work
whenever and then do their schooling
whenever works for their family then is
that something they're not so what I'm
understanding is that's not something
they're currently allowed to do my
understanding and I will gladly check
this as well but my understanding is is
that H schools and homeschool programs
have to adhere to the school district
the purpose of homeschooling is not to
do it as you want to do it the purpose
of homeschooling by most of the the
parents who want to homeschool is
because they have their way of wanting
to present the information the
educational information that their
children have to learn but they are
subject to the district to which they
are affiliated with so if you're
homeschooling in B you're subject to
Bose's school district and and School
District
rules I don't think we
need that is
outside this committee is responsible
for so I don't think debating that issue
to
wait uh representative kahill thank you
Mr chair and thank you m
mcra um I'm not sure what's the
sponsor's intent was but this this bill
refers to no youth under 16 years of age
that's not the 17y old that we're
familiar with uh so that's a concern but
but I think
um where's my
as far as the the Department of Labor
does inspections wage and hour
inspections and if you did if you find
cards uh time sheets for kids who are uh
teenagers and they are not working when
they're they're at work when they're
supposed to be in school that's when
this becomes I think what's in the word
of Mr Summers might be called a
gotcha so is that that's is this is how
it would become known to the department
through a through an inspection and and
if I are you saying that if they had all
the documents from the school and the
parent then then there wouldn't be any
issue as far as the
employer so the the inspectors would go
in and they would look exactly like you
were saying they would look at the time
cards they would see that a child who
was supposed to be in school was not in
school but was actually working so then
the question becomes okay does this
child have a schedule that would allow
him to work during this particular
period of time
if the employer has that information in
the file if it has a letter from the
school that says this child has this
required schedule which is slightly
different than the full schedule for
that District then that would be taken
into account and the inspectors would
have to make sure that everything is in
order the biggest problem that the
inspectors have had to this point when
there are issues with when a student is
allowed to work and not allowed to work
is the fact that we are not entitled to
get any schedules from the schools that
are outside the district schedule that's
actually listed on the website in order
to get that we need authorization from
the parent um and so it becomes a
problem for us to be able to prove it
but if the documents were in there then
the inspectors would have to look at the
rest of it and determine whether or not
there's anything else missing thank you
representative
cokum thank you Mr chair thank you M
mcra for taking my question um I have
two actually if I'm allowed to ask the
two it says in the law that we um will
provide work certificates for these
children to work that they must they
they shall have a work certificate with
a couple of exceptions is this something
that maybe could be incorporated as part
of their work certificate to allow them
the ability to to be able to work um in
a certain schedule I I'm not really
familiar with the work certificates so I
apologize for
that I think the answer to that un
unfortunately is the legal answer which
is it depends it's going
to there are things that we would have
to look at whether or not the schedule
changes the schedule could change on a
quarterly basis their schedule could
change on a semester basis um is that
something that you know would require
additional information being submitted
um I think that there
are so many questions and so many
problems with respect to trying to do
something here where we are
really trying to almost individualize an
employees schedule to fit something that
an employer can allow one person to work
this hour and this person to work this
hour I think that the problems are just
so replete throughout this that I'm not
100% sure that I would be able to site
every single thing that an inspector
would be looking for versus what the law
is going to require of them to do I'd
like to see this a little bit further
down the the line and then take it to
our Inspection Division for review thank
you on that um subject I'd like to
transition that into the work programs
that they already have with school kids
today so kids are allowed to attend
school during a certain time and then
they are allowed to go off and work on
their job or at a job as part of their
education process so there must be some
method that we're managing that right
now as well so would this not fall into
a similar
situation from what I've seen and this
is not 100% with everyone but from what
I've seen is that whenever there is any
kind of a program with a students in
just for instance school in the morning
in high school and then in the afternoon
they're going to either a different type
of school whether it's a technical
school or they're going to a job as part
of an apprenticeship or as part of what
they're doing in high school there's
still documentation with the school and
that documentation can be obtained
either through parental consent or um
having the the School provide an actual
copy with the parent giving consent to
so follow up thank
you so am I understanding correctly that
the way that we're describing this
happening today is
that youth in order for a youth to be
able to work they have to get permission
from the school rather than from their
parent so the school would be control
even if they're they're homeschool
they're homeschooled in school has
nothing to do with their education no
okay no no if I may answer this is
talking about not getting permission to
work this is getting a a a definitive
ability to work because school is in
session and an employer saying school is
in session how do I know you can or
cannot work if you're putting that
language into this bill that says when
they're not required to be at school
this isn't a matter of whether um the
parent is asking the question this is
the employer trying to find out whether
or not they're going to violate the law
by allowing a student to work from 1 to
3:00 in the afternoon when school
technically is in session so no this is
not the school telling them when they
can work this is what the program is
it's not the parents telling them when
they can work it's what the program is
and the rest of it is going to be
parental
discussion I do have a question and I
think you might have already told told
me you want to go back and research this
but do you you said they will be
violating the law and the sponsor said
she couldn't find she didn't know which
law we were talking about do you know
case I would think that it's the and and
again this is the one that I wanted to
go back and research and make sure but I
think what we're looking at here is the
uh the the portion of the wage and hour
law when it talks to to the youth about
when they're allowed to work during the
school year during the work week when
they were allowed to work during the uh
vacation periods uh vacation Summers um
and making sure that they're not working
in excess of their hours and and things
like that that's where I want to compare
them to um if I said there was a
violation I that was a mistake because I
really don't know the answer to it which
is why I want to do the research on it
all right thanks I didn't mean to no
that's okay that's okay
and uh representative dgo and then I see
you thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um maybe the
Department of Labor can provide this for
an answer to I know you have to you're
mentioning having to provide um May the
school calendar something along those
lines to an employer so they would know
the school hours if a child is
homeschooled they're not getting a
school calendar so would the Department
of Labor or the employer would it be
sufficient to have the letter of intent
that the school district signed off
saying you're okay to homeschool would
that would that
count well obviously I can't speak to
whether or not that particular issue
would count but my understanding and it
has been strongly um instilled in me
that homeschoolers have to follow the
district schedule so even if a
homeschooler themselves do not have a
district schedule themselves they have
to follow as I said if you're
homeschooling in Bow you follow the
district schedule when I'm talking about
a district schedule I'm not talking
about the hours of the day I'm talking
about the days of the week that they're
off if Bo is off on Friday for a teacher
workday then a homeschooler can be off
on Friday if Bo is off for a week for
for and I'm sorry for B I'm just using
one word I apologize but if Bo is off
this particular week for their winter
break then that homeschooler will be off
that week for a particular for that
break that's the district schedule that
I'm talking about I'm not talking about
a daily schedule because that's where I
wanted to do a little bit more research
on as to whether or not that has to
comport if the school is 8 to4 does
homeschooling have to be 8 to4 my
initial instinct is no it does not but
I'd like to do more research on that and
that was pursuant to representative
Granger's question too so I will gladly
share that research follow up follow all
right so yeah can you
I would be interested in KN that I'm a
homeschooled dad myself and I actually
I'm thinking it's actually the other way
around we don't follow the school
district calendar and I I'll give you a
perfect
example February vacation we take the
vacation the week after because we don't
want to pay the up price in ski tickets
for the vacation week so we just do it a
week after but I think as a homeschooled
family you're allowed to do that now if
I wanted to let my kids work that week
I'm curious as to see the stance on that
as to why by I'm just taking the
vacation the week after um you know and
even our schooling schedule is not
always the same we some H School
families school all summer long take a
longer winter break they do all sorts of
stuff so I I think it would be good to
get some clarity on that because I think
that's a huge I think the intent of this
bill was really the mass population was
affecting homeschool families and laying
a homeschool child who gets out at noon
be able to work for the afternoon um
that's going to be the biggest
population here so I think if there's
nothing prohibiting them then maybe this
bill is not necessarily needed but if
there is something prohibiting a
homeschool child who might work on
Alternate schedule then uh then I think
there's something to be said for this
bill and we need to figure out a way to
work on to correct it or whatever so if
you could just provide some clarity
that'd be
awesome after I do some research perfect
thank you representative
stop thank you thank you for taking my
question question Miss McGrath um I'm
going to go in the way back machine here
um some 50 years ago this bill in
particular I want to note is refers to
Children between the ages of 12 and 15
there are different sets of rules for
for um students who are 16 and older but
um back in in the day um when I and my
friends were 14 years old I went with a
number of them to the school district
office to get a work permit that would
allow them to work at age 14 in the
summer youth program or at the local
McDonald's is that um law still in place
and
um I'm just just curious how um if the
laws have changed since the
1970s thank you I going to Sid step your
question with this answer which is that
from this bill it seems like there are a
lot of questions there's a lot of
concerns there's also a lot of um
information that's coming in there's a
lot of information that's being asked of
the Department of Labor and I want to
make sure that what I'm providing is
accurate information instead of having
to come back and tell you that I gave
you wrong
information uh so with your permission
representative strob and uh chairman
seaworth I would like to do research on
that to find out um there are people at
our Inspections Division that would be
able to answer these questions very
quickly and provide me with the research
and then I would be more than happy to
put it in a summary and send it to the
entire
committee and I'll offer I I like that
answer and I I I will look forward to to
your response I will provide a quick
answer from my perspective as having
been on this committee a number of years
and having worked on some of that um the
the first thing I'd point out because a
couple people have said it this
bill and I think it's one of the
problems with this bill but as it was
proposed it actually has sections that
some are for the under 16 and some are
for 16 and 17 so you have to be careful
of which section you're reading when you
try to connect it and and it is a very
different legal landscape for those two
groups so that's one caution um in terms
of that work certificate for the younger
group that it it is still in law um
however it has changed and it changed
somebody else might remember it was a
few years ago where it addressed this
issue of someone who's not associated
with a school district it allows the
parents to provide
the certificate of authorization in that
case um a lot of the schools and it it
uh former representative the department
brought up there's a triplicate form
with three different colors and a lot of
the schools actually use that and one of
the question is we really make them use
that that colored form and and the
answer is no it's not required but
because it's what the department has if
a district asks well what do what do we
do what do we need for this they they'll
provide the form that's been in use for
years so partial answer to tied us over
until we get the complete
answer um representative
blow thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question uh I'd just like some
clarification when you when you said
that um you know that employers uh
wouldn't wouldn't want to are prohibited
from um you know changing schedules and
juggling schedules like like uh you know
with different kids uh you know if you
had a homeschool kid that could come to
work at 6:00 in the morning he doesn't
start school till 12:00 you know with
his parents um and you said that uh you
know that employers would uh I wasn't
sure if you said prohibited or
no they're not okay so an employer is
not allowed to contact a school district
and say I need a kid schedule um the uh
fura rules the uh federal education
protection act rules they basically say
that no one else has access to those
records except for the child and the
parent so the the employer can't do that
the employer can however either ask for
the parent to provide notification from
the school um I don't see anything in
there that allows for just a simple note
but this is just for a protective
measure that's uh one of the reasons
that this rule is in place it's just so
that somebody doesn't call up and find
out where a child is at any given time
sure do you want to ask it so uh the
question was he asked if you said rule
or law and I think you you mentioned an
acronym it sounded like a
federal it's furpa federal education
rights and Privacy Act F RP
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr M uh
representative love brought it up and
you mentioned that it was a rule or a
law that didn't prevent the parent I
said rule that's right is is is it in
your labor rules or is it a rule of law
it's under the federal it's under the
federal F rules so it's oh it's under it
the federal rule Federal rule federal
law yeah we'll clarify that too if you'd
like I just want to make sure it's not
in our labor laws that we're overlooking
here in the
state I believe we follow the federal on
that one perfect thank you thank you Mr
chairman and if I can before and I
apologize chairman seaworth a lot of the
questions that are being asked and while
I'm more than happy to do whatever
research I can from the Department of
Labor a lot of the questions that are
being asked are actually questions from
the Department of Education and so I
cannot speak to the Department of
Education and I do not ever want to
speak for them
uh so I just want to make sure that you
understand that I'm looking at this more
from the Department of Labor's
perspective how we would treat a case
that came in the concerns that we're
getting phone calls on trying to find
information and how they can get
information so I I'm not trying to um
sideswipe any of your your questions and
I do believe though the Department of
Education might be helpful to get some
information from yes and that's what I
was going to say too is that so for
example that
law the furpa is not labor law it's it's
education law and likewise truancy falls
under education law not labor law what
would be interesting as you do your
research um if you can clarify it for us
is if the Department of Labor in
enforcing
something is relying
on a body of law that's outside of Labor
so for example if it says something in
treny that you can't do X does an
inspector from Department of Labor come
in and say well you know it says it over
in this other area because that's what
that confuses me and probably some other
members of the committee is where when
we look at our labor laws if there's
something that's not not there but yet
inspectors still rely on we're going to
miss that I think it's a good question I
have no problem doing that thank
you another question representative
kahill thank you Mr chair and thank you
Mr McGrath patience so I just wanted to
get it out there that in for the the
employer that's operating with a an with
where their employees coming from two or
more school districts uh anybody can get
the the schedule online they all have
them there and the employer can have
them and and sort them and color code
them by which employer so that it's easy
for them to know who can work what days
and what hours is that correct yes and
that we're talking about the district
schedules that are out there obviously
not individual student schedules right
but the district schedules are out there
at every single school's website and
follow up and this is what the
department inspectors hang their hat
on at this point in time yes if there's
going to be some kind of change or some
kind of um alteration to whatever's
going on here then we might have to look
a little bit further and see whether or
not there is a a student who is working
during school hours but has the ability
you thank you very
much if there are any other questions um
I actually got another card so I'm very
excited to call the next person you
nobody else knew I had
this um so thank you very much and uh
appreciate you taking some some some
heat from us there
yeah and so next I'd like to ask Mike
Summers uh of the New Hampshire lodging
and Restaurant Association to come up
and speak he's not signed in in favor or
against the bill but hopefully with his
knowledge of the industry he can help
clarify some of the questions that we've
been having uh thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee he might have
oversold my expertise but we'll do what
we can um so we are not necessarily in
support or opposed to this bill but we
have concerns and the concerns are
that as a business owner um you are
required to comply with both state and
federal regulations and currently the
way the the statute is written for the
under 16 youth um we already have a a
conflict in here right so right now in
the New Hampshire statute no earlier
than 7:00 a.m. and no later than 9:00
p.m. the federal standard is you can't
work past 7:00 p.m. and I can't tell you
how many business owners I know who get
and to paraphrase Representatives
offering of my testimony earlier uh a
gotcha because now they have a two-hour
window that New Hampshire Department of
Labor tells them sure by Statute you're
fine but under the US Federal audit you
are not fine and then you see in the
paper as I'm sure you all have we have
all these youth labor violations well a
big part of that is because there's
discrepancies between state and federal
so what I would re certainly request of
this committee is to take a hard look at
what the federal standard is and try to
align our standard with that standard
because we don't want to get in these
situations where businesses are trying
to meet two different standards and
depending on if you're a new business
owner you're a veteran you may or may
not know what the rules are and
depending on who you talk to you get a
different answer to what the rules are
and so that creates a lot of conflict so
would certainly um request that you take
a look at that for example in on line um
lines four and five it strikes out more
than 3 hours per day on school days and
23 hours per uh week during school weeks
that's the federal standard so that has
to stay in because that is is the way it
has to has to operate the the other
comment I'll make and you you guys had a
very robust discussion but the other
thing I'll comment I'll make is that
this statute is permissive for the
business owner right this doesn't affect
school schedules or anything else I
think what the department is essentially
trying to get that is they have no other
standard for homeschooled kids so they
so they have to default to whatever
standard is in that locality which would
be the school schedule so um you know is
there a way to provide greater
flexibility within the statute for that
perhaps um I'm certainly not an expert
in it but um but I just I caution the
committee in going too far in in uh
trampling all over the standard between
state and federal because that's going
to create huge issues for the industry
to try to comply with and we'll get back
to the standard representative cworth
you were here a couple years ago when we
fixed the 16 and 17 year olds to 35
hours a week and took out that massive
sliding chart that was just a nightmare
nobody used it so um so I'll end with
that and I'm happy to try to answer any
questions all right thank you any
questions representative
C going be a little bit of a
plug so um following up on your comments
about this not being in conformance with
the federal standards uh would there be
a difference
with um the bills we're trying to pass
with marijuana in the workforce and that
that's that's actually not authorized by
the federal government but we're seeing
that that's okay but this would be
handled differently is is there
correlation between the two I'm no
expert in this subject matter but I will
say that uh alcohol is regulated by the
states or is deferred to the states um
so I think there are certain areas where
the states uh have their own right and I
would also say that in the labor rules
the state has the ability to set their
own standards the problem for the imple
the implementation of it at the business
level the operator level is because you
now have two standards that you have to
comply with and then knowing which is
the most restrictive that you have to
comply with that creates the
challenge I'm sorry did I say alcohol or
did I say marijuana I was using it as an
example if you believe it was it was was
the marijuana that's still against
federal law right I'm not arguing the
point
no for other
questions representative
Granger thank you uh feel free to not
answer if you don't know um I'm not
going to hold you to it I love making
stuff up okay um do is it okay right now
for a business to hire a homeschooler to
work during public school hours where
that homeschooler isn't actually
doing any homeschool work uh that was
asked of of the department was around um
uh you know work experience type uh
activities and there is a whole
certification and verification process a
business has to go through there are
there are rigid um uh guard rails on a
reporting mechanism from the business
back to the school so it's a little bit
different than just working a shift so
um but as to whether or not a
homeschooled student can work during uh
school hour
I I I don't want to pretend that I know
the answer to that I do not thank you
further questions representative kahill
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
Summers so would you would you feel
comfortable in saying that businesses
find it easier when the laws are
consistent is that what I'm
getting yes thank you representative
St um thank you um in this um sixth
paragraph it says that um
uh 16 and 17 year olds who are enrolled
in school shall work no more than 35
hours during that work week um but then
it says that unless a youth's required
attendance while in school is less than
35 hours per week in which case the
youth shall be permitted to work at any
time the youth is not required to attend
school and up here it says that 48 hours
is the limit on um during vacations and
um so are those numbers the 48h hour top
number for um youth or younger persons
in uh 35 hours per week during school
sessions are those also Federal numbers
or are we again
um not again I would encourage you to
double check that with uh people smarter
than I but I will say that you know the
top section is for under 16 the lower
section is for um 1617
at the federal level 16 and 177 there
are no restrictions you're essentially
an adult um it's the under 16 where it
gets a little bit uh slippery but I
believe I believe that the 48 hours is
uh accurate for uh during their outside
the school year um if they're working
those hours Etc but I believe that
aligns but I would I would encourage you
to double check that and and it I know
some of it is in section 7 which wasn't
included in the bill language but it's
the next one down that talks about this
the vacation time versus school time and
there is somewhere else and I do not
remember where it is where there's a
overall Pro uh upper limit for under 18s
and it it depends on the industry so all
of this stuff aside in another section
it falls back on an absolute cap so it
gets difficult sometimes to try to
take one piece and
it any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your input thank you so much
and uh I think everybody fled the room
with that but if there's anyone else who
wishes to speak please um say so
otherwise uh the sign in sheets on its
way
up
so which one's this so on that bill no
one signed in and on um the previous
Bill no one signed in so with that I
will close the hearing on HB 159 and we
will be in recess until 300 p.m. when
person
so if everyone could uh take their seats
and get ready for the next hearing I'd
pardon my mother has a bridge at 4 so
she wants to make sure we start on time
you know I actually told her the other
day on the telephone that I uh I say mom
you know I always talk about you and the
and you're always watching she was
I all right it being the witching hour
of 3:00 I'm going to get back with
business here like to uh repres uh yeah
acknowledge uh Vice chairman
seaworth and and you know I think the
only thing that I've ever done that has
impressed my son who's 10 years old is
when I showed him there's a YouTube
channel that I'm on YouTube for It's
like wow you must be important
time all right so um I didn't know where
the the sheets were for online signups
when I read those last ones so now I
have them and I'll just go through for
HB
1375 four online signed up in support
none opposed none neutral and for HP
1519 there were 23 in support and 30
them was 15
you did read it
1375 the first one the first one I read
was the um Severance agreements and I
just I had both sheets both blue sheets
that's why I read them both and then the
1519 was the work hours for
youth these were as of 8:25 this morning
so they were you know confused what am I
missing 1522 I didn't say we said it
earlier
we have oh you said that I did
he realized that we can still
accept you can do it till midnight so
room I did it was 28 to zero that sounds
one I'm going to open the hearing on
House Bill 1648
point of order Mr Mr chair point of
order in my left hand I have
HB uh 1648 19 or from 2024 in my right
hand I have S SP 46 from
2023 these bills are nearly identical
and by my knowledge that's a violation
of house rules to do the same bill in
succeeding years of the same term um
what's up with
this while I have not spoken directly
with the speaker it is my understanding
that the um off uh the legislative
Services did not want
to
um draft the bill for that very same
reason a um request of the speaker was
made to overrule that request and that
was
provided I have similar thoughts I guess
my suggestion would be since we've heard
this bill
by this uh committee there's probably no
again
um the speaker uh made a um overruled
legislative services and allowed the
bill to be heard uh allowed the bill to
be drafted the bill uh was given to me
uh I have to hear it fair enough the
last point I'll make is that uh s SP 46
in
2023 um from the committee was itl 20 to
you going to call Representative uh
Bill thank you welcome to the labor
committee thank you Mr chairman and
thank you members of the committee for
uh for hearing my testimony by way of
introduction my name is Jim kofalt I
represent Hillsboro County District 32
which is comprised the towns of Wilton
Temple and new
ipswitch um so House Bill 1648 attempts
to clarify the uh the procedures by
which employees could be paid using an
electronic debit card and I guess I will
Begin by um addressing the concern uh
that was raised a few moments ago uh
because there are C certainly quite a
few similarities between this and Senate
Bill 46 there was some back and forth
discussion with OS and the speaker's
office and um ultimately it was
determined that the the changes that
were introduced into this bill uh were
were material to the extent that it is
not exactly the same bill and therefore
is was was deemed permissible by the
speaker's office so so I guess I will I
I will I will go directly to the
specific changes because I think there
were some concerns that were
raised last year with Senate Bill
46 um you know one of which was would an
employee potentially be responsible for
uh fees uh this bill affirmatively
asserts that employees would not be
responsible for for fees associated with
a lost or stolen card um and it also uh
asserts that uh funds would be available
uh there would be a number of free
resources uh where employees could um
could use the debit cards or could
withdraw cash from uh most ATM machines
um but the bill this version of the bill
also stipulates that the employer would
be required to provide a list of uh such
locations to uh to the employees um
finally I know that there was a concern
about collective bargaining agreements
and whether or not this would um
supersede the rights of of unions to uh
to negotiate the method of payment with
their uh with their employers and again
uh the current version of the bill
specifically um excludes uh unions
protects union workers uh in that
scenario um so I've sort of covered the
the the latter part of my uh of my bill
introduction first uh I guess for the
sake of of uh completeness I'll just say
that I think that in you know we live in
a world right now where payments by and
large are electronic uh paper checks are
an element of that um but or an element
of of the way we do business uh but but
in today's world payments happen by a
large electronically uh payer checks are
very slow and inefficient by
comparison um electronic debit cards I
would argue actually give employees
particularly employ employees who do
don't have access to a bank account with
a direct deposit uh a faster easier and
more flexible way of accessing their
funds um so having said that I think
that the bill before you does address
some of the concerns that were noted as
deficiencies in Senate Bill
46 um and I would urge you to uh to
consider this bill
um and consider consider voting ought to
pass on this bill that concludes my
introduction
questions I don't know which one you put
up
first
sorry Granger followed by uh grego
followed by thank you Mr chair um so is
cards um I will leave it for for others
to uh to provide a definitive answer to
that but my understanding is that you
know our our current law does not
provide for it so it would be a problema
problematic scenario would you believe
that I've received payment with a
payroll card in New
Hampshire that comes as as a surprise to
youo thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question on
line 16 says uh employee well starting
on line 15 employee is unable to access
page oh sorry
page one two three well actually yeah
technically it's the first
page it says if an employee is unable to
access their wages due a tech due to a
technical or processing defect can you
describe what a technical or a
processing defect is um I imagine that a
card with a bad mag stripe or otherwise
unreadable might be one example of a uh
a technical problem that would prevent
the an employee from Gaining access to
their funds okay follow up follow up so
then on lines 21 and 22 on the same page
um actually starting on line 20 says if
an employee debit card is lost stolen
damaged such that the funds are no
longer accessible to the employee the
employer shall provide the employee with
a replacement employee debit card within
24 hours of being notified
so is the intent of this bill now that
we know the technical or processing
defect is not the fault of the employer
but actually probably the manufacturer
and the fact that a card was lost or
stolen is also not because of the
employer's wrongdoing it's all because
of the employee or somebody else that's
out of their
control is the intent of this bill to
punish the employer and have them come
back on a weekend when they're away to
pay the employee on time because that's
how this bill's written
well I think the the intention of the
bill is to provide some additional
flexibility uh paper check checks can be
inconvenient and costly both for the
employee and the employer there's
nothing in this bill that precludes an
employer from continuing to to pay by
papercheck if they
choose
um the the concerns that were raised the
last time this bill came up were we want
to make sure that people have access to
their funds
um and that that would be promptly
replaced so if that is something that
that the committee believes needs to be
tightened up then I would be happy to
work with uh with any members of the
committee who are who are willing to uh
to work on an amendment to to come up
with a solution to that
problem thank
you have aani followed by
Sullivan um okay Brian uh he's yielded
to you thank you um just uh addressing
representative Granger's uh question if
you look at the
bill there are methods a b c and d d
currently is the payroll card so it is
not illegal to use a payroll card now
what this bill does is it allows an
employer to eliminate the paper check
and uh require someone to use the
payroll card so it's illegal to require
someone to use a payroll card right now
but it's not illegal to pay through
payroll
card it's also my understanding
representative aani thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative calt
um aside from uh representative Drago's
questions uh this is forcing the
employer to technically pay an employee
twice if they're unable to access their
funds with either through a processing
defect or that their card is
gone um is that the intent as well is to
double pay an employee because they
can't access their
funds no the the intent would be to uh
would be to ensure that the employee has
access to the funds if the employer
chooses electronic payment card as a
method of payment there's nothing in
this bill that says that an employer has
to choose that as a method of payment
they can continue to issue paper checks
um they can according to line eight they
can pay it in cash presumably with
lawful money in the United States so um
it is it it
is codifying one
additional option that an employer would
have so if an employer chooses not to
because they have the kinds of concerns
that have been raised there um then by
all means they they would not be
required to do so um what this what this
would do is it would protect the
employees in the event that they have
for some reason are unable to access
their funds the employer would be
required to make sure that they can can
replace that lost or stolen or defective
card within 24
hours clarification um if you have
questions about like because I also have
the same questions about protocol you
lose it what happens new card how the
other one gets deactivated the funds
whatever um there's someone from ADP
that's going to be speaking afterwards
so maybe other than the representative
that those questions on technical stuff
I would ask you to wait till the next
speaker but you're welcome to ask any
other question questions you have I just
because this this is again this is the
same bill we've seen before and this is
the same issue that I have come up with
lines 15 through 18 you're forcing the
employer to re with the intelligence of
the chair forcing the employer to repay
that employee if they got paid on Friday
their cards not good on Saturday this is
telling me as an employer I shall
immediately pay them till they get their
new card or replace their card in 24
hours now I know the ADP is not open
24/7 so if I'm using ADP as an example
they're they're not going to get a
replacement card till Monday so I'm on
the hook for paying that employee twice
before that card is active and how do I
recoup the payment if I've paid them
twice because this is forcing me to
between lines 15 and 18 thank you thank
you for the question so again I I will
uh in in keeping with the Chairman's
comment I will say I think that there
are others who can probably speak to the
mechanics of it more accurately than I
can um having said that if you're
issuing a a card and that card is
subsequently lost or stolen just as you
can cancel a credit card or cancel a
debit card uh the idea here is you would
be able to cancel the uh the use of the
um of the electronic payment card that
has just been reported lost or stolen in
the case of paper checks there is a
similar process uh in which there has to
be a stop payment issued and stop
payments cost a lot of money uh but
without them there is a risk that
somebody somewhere picks up that check
and manages to to cash it so um it's
actually in some respects I believe a
safer means of of ensuring that
everybody walks away whole thank you Mr
you repr Broody thank you Mr chairman um
this issue
about lost to stolen cards or a
defective card if this went through
would you be opposed to most employers
will pay you withhold a week's pay like
you work all week and you get paid the
next Friday or the next Thursday would
you be opposed to anybody who chooses
this to be paid by
Tuesday of the next
week I think we would have to explore
that it sounds to me like it might
complicate things the current law has
one one standard as far as the timing of
payments relative to work completed um
and it seems seems to me that it would
somewhat complicate things if we were to
um create different standards for
different payment methods but I
certainly would be open to
discussion representative kahill thank
you thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question uh
you referenced earlier you wanted to
improve
flexibility but I'm afraid that the
flexibility for the employee is is uh is
reduced if their preferen is to a paper
check and that's that's no longer an
option here it's replaced with the uh
payroll card which for many people is
problematic uh fees and all the sort of
thing and as as we've learned from my
colleague Mr Granger payroll cards are
being used now and I imagine if he had a
difficulty he would make another
Arrangement but if this law was to pass
he could not choose a paper check if if
that if this was removed moved do you
see a conflict
here
um I I actually don't because I believe
and and again this is my opinion it's
not necessarily going to be everybody's
opinion but I think we've all seen
scenarios where it's Friday afternoon
and everybody's rushing down to the bank
before it closes to cash their check um
with electronic payment cards you
actually don't have to go to the bank
you can go to an ATM 24/7 anytime and
withdraw money without paying a fee um
and have cash at your fingertips having
said that I think if the committee deems
it important to protect
somebody's option to still get a paper
check I think that that's something that
again we could discuss in an amendment
and see how we could come to a a an
agreement on on what that would look
like solve that problem follow up follow
up uh so as we talked earlier the the
payroll check is the payroll check is an
option payroll cards are an option so if
we leave it as it is now we we needn't
worry but when someone goes and uses
their payroll debit card uh isn't there
like withdrawal it is isn't just one
withdrawal and then after that there's a
fee and isn't and aren't the debit card
companies making fees incurring uh
profits from the more people using these
cards uh generally speaking the fees if
you use it debit card at a merchant um
the merchant is paying fees so if I go
into Home Depot and I use a credit card
or a debit card um I'm not paying a
markup on the product that I'm buying um
there is a a small percentage and
usually a flat fee of something like a
quarter uh in addition to that per
transaction that is charged to the
merchant by the credit card
processor um as a consumer I don't pay
that um like wise one of the concerns
here uh with with the Senate Bill uh
that was very similar was um was this
idea that if I go to an ATM machine I'm
going to be charged a fee in fact um
they virtually any ATM machine that
accepts Visa and MasterCard um would be
would be usable to withdraw funds from
this and in this version of the bill it
would be required that the employer Prov
provide a list of such locations to the
employee so that they could withdraw
funds without a fee so um so there are
no built-in fees for for employees in
using these
cards follow up so
the the merchant pays the fees for the
convenience of of having the transaction
use the pay but doesn't the merchant
have to pass those fees on to the
consumer or you know if he simply absorb
ABS them uh you're hurting the small
business operator aren't you
um ask a question okay would you
believe that I I find it ask a question
that could be answered by the T are are
the fees like if you were here last week
you would have heard uh Mr veu speaking
that we that people when they use credit
cards with the restaurants there's
there's a markup I think rough 3% or
four 4% that the restaurants are have to
absorb and pass on and isn't it likely
that if people weren't using cards with
the frequency that they're encouraged to
we might have lower prices when we go
out to eat or or buy something in the
store
um it's hard to disagree with that but I
but I also tend to believe that payment
using payment cards is not going to
um is is not going to statistically
change the the the volume of
transactions that we're running through
payment cards I I will tell you that
personally I very seldom pay in cash I
buy almost everything with a payment
card and it's something that Merchants
build into the cost of doing business as
followup uh in the case of your own
personal credit card uh are you being
rewarded you know incentivized by the
credit card company would that be the
case with a payroll
card in fact there are uh some
incentives available using some of these
cards I will let the the next speaker uh
address that question but my
understanding that is that yes employees
would actually have access to some of
those kinds of um points programs that
might benefit them if they use a card
over the long term thank you
representative thank you Mr chairman
if you can indulge me a little to kind
of um piggyback on on what
representative kahill is talking about
uh with regard to the payroll card if I
was to use that in the cafeteria
downstairs in the State Building there's
a sign in that says that I'm going to be
charged a 4% transaction fee so am I
then being charged 4% to use my own
payroll because it's given to me on a
card in in the rare instance that you
have a merchant who's charging you a a
fee for using a payment card yes that
would be the case um under those
circumstances like say you could pay
cash you could go to an ATM machine one
to one of the many ATM machines where
you could withdraw funds for free and
pay cash without incurring that
additional
cost follow so I guess that would be the
point right because then it's not
treated as cash so if I'm not able to
get to an ATM card I mean an ATM machine
to take cash out to pay for my
lunch this is not being handled the same
way as cash then so now I'm being forced
to into another path which actually does
cause more it does incur more expense on
my part to to be fair if the alternative
is that you're taking a paper check to a
bank then you're also being forced to
what I would argue is an even more
inconvenient path to spend your
Mason thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um could you
elaborate just a little bit on the ATM
machines because in the past I've my
businesses have owned some ATM
machines the fees come to the owners of
the ATM machines so these aren't all ATM
machines they're not private Banking ATM
machines they're ATM machines owned by
credit card company I I will defer to uh
me representative buard thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question
um would you believe that um you can
join a credit union for $5 and get free
checking
account and that way you're eliminating
the paper trail and everything is done
electronically uh thank you for the
question yes um I am proudly a member of
One of New Hampshire's First Credit
Unions first in the country I believe um
and I that remains an option and it's
something that quite honestly I would
encourage people to do when my son was
getting his first job I encouraged him
to sign up for direct deposit because I
think that's also a very efficient way
of managing your money and uh what I was
concerned with him about was that he
would put his paper check somewhere lose
it forget to cash it and have to clean
that mess up years later or months later
so um so in fact I think that uh that
that is another very good option for
people who are looking for an efficient
electronic means of getting
paid representative
ccum thank you again Mr chairman I'm
going to get off of this subject and
move on to something different on page
one line 10 um I see that it states by
direct deposit we used it currently
states by direct deposit with written
authorization of the employee to the
banks can you explain why uh you've
struck out the with written consent to
the employee and I've noticed in a
couple of areas we seem to have taken
out the written consent of the employee
so what would be the reasoning behind
that um I am afraid I don't have a good
answer to that I will I will revert to
OS and and figure out why that was
um
well personally I agree
that um direct
deposit provides immediate access you
don't have to worry about losing a check
some of these other things it is rare in
this
committee to actually mandate employees
do
something what is the what is the
underlying
need to force to require or
mandate employers
take something other than a check I.E in
this case a bank
card thank you for the question so I
think um in framing this as a mandate I
think the way it is written right now it
it does in fact take paper checks off
the table in other words a an
employer certainly has the option of
issuing paper checks but as this bill is
written they would not be obligated to
offer that option to their employees
having said that I think if that is the
sticking point then I I think we can we
can talk about an amendment that would
solve that particular problem the the
issue here I think is opening up a a
newer more modern form of electronic
payment that is not provided for in law
today and while I I respectfully
appreciate the comment that somebody
here has been paid with an electronic
debit card um it is not clear to me that
that is um that that is something that
is supported in current statute so this
would support it in current statute it
would add a new capability and I guess
that that that's how I see this as
something that adds a new a new more
efficient more flexible option for
paying
employees
that is not the way we see the bill from
what you said if you said and you want
pay cards to be one of those other
here I don't think anyone would care
maybe he's
fine I don't think that's what your bill
has done here and that's the the I know
that's not a question I I think you just
said something totally different from
what what we are feeling so maybe we'll
testimony
represent I guess I will point out for a
second
time payroll cards are presently an
option for um employers this is not
making them available for the first time
under current
law you've got uh Roman numeral I or one
a b c and d current law buy a payroll
card provided that the employer shall
provide the employee at least one free
means to withdraw up to the and
including the full amount so essentially
that is currently an
option what this bill does is exactly
what the chairman was uh indicating it
continues to provide this option but it
it eliminates the obligation to provide
a papercheck
and it allows an employer to force the
employee to take a payroll card instead
of that check that's what the bill
does would you believe
right we're going to get back to the
questioning sorry we're just trying to
have a little flexibility here in our
conversation representative
cul am I correct in understanding that
it also removes the free means statement
as well so it removes the ability for us
to access our money for free um because
those words have been struck from the
the line okay um kind of get back to the
way it should be um I'm not going to
answer that question it's not I'm not
testifying if you'd like to ask the um
individual is testifying that question
he can either answer that or wait for
I just trying to get back to the the
protocol if that's all right and I'm the
one that broke it so I know it's my
fault my fault
so any other questions for the
representative seeing none thank you
rules so allum sir I apologize if I uh
don't do justice to your name is this
Pete
isburg thank you ice
Iceberg ADP
welcome back to the labor
committee thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee we appreciate the
opportunity to uh speak to you again
about this uh topic we think it's very
important uh and I understand there's
some uh uh sensitivity here to U you
know employee rights and so forth so
I'll speak to that I think we are happy
to uh to work with the committee on
language that um you would find
acceptable to move us closer to an
environment in which um payroll could be
uh administered as much as possible
electronically so uh it may not be 100%
for some time but um you know we'd like
to move there um as best we can so again
uh my name is Pete Iceberg I serve as
vice president of government relations
for ADP ADP is the one of the largest
payroll companies in the nation we pay
um roughly one of every six us
workers and um really our our motivation
in uh putting forth this bill is to help
small businesses
um and you know minimize their expenses
and so forth it's very helpful for small
businesses as at present um there's a a
vast minority of employees that still
are getting paper checks it's like 3 to
5% of employees if you're a small
business and um everything's running
fairly smoothly electronically but you
got one or two employees they're still
getting paper checks it's it's very
costly uh Bank of America did a study uh
to the effect of um you know to
administer paper checks including
issuing U mailing reconciling sometimes
stop payments and replacement things
like that uh cost of fraud um paper
checks are are very prone to fraud is
about $4 up to $20 per check uh for
small business who administer so this is
kind of a s cost savings measure it also
from our perspective very importantly
helps employers to comply with the wage
and hour
laws and the issue there is that you
know for some reason you know this bill
um the wage and nrow laws have always
made it a huge priority to pay employees
on time and we totally agree with that
um so this this actually helps employers
to do that in contrast for example using
a papercheck uh if an employee for
whatever reason can't get to the
workplace to pick up their check on
payday maybe they're just sick that day
maybe they're sick for a week um but
somehow it's okay not to pay that person
if they can't get to the workplace or
they can't get to the bank or there's
you know there's a snowstorm there's
adverse weather for whatever reason if
you can't deliver that paper check to a
person somehow despite the strong wage
and hour laws everybody's you know kind
of like well you know can't help the
weather uh you'll get paid next week
sometime when when the US mail shows up
we'll just mail your check that
shouldn't be okay electronic pay
resolves that issue you so even if
there's a snowstorm bad weather you
can't get to work you're sick you're on
vacation whatever the the issue is you
you don't have to get to the workplace
to get that physical check and to take
that uh to the
Bank um and there was you know concerns
about U the fees associated with this
and really um if you're getting a
payroll card you shouldn't have to pay
any fees whatsoever you should be able
to use that card anywhere you go you
know pay just you know swipe your card
to to spend the money or transfer the
funds or however you spend uh your your
your payroll
dollars uh but the only way you're
you're paying fees with these payroll
cards if you if you're using an out of
network ATM and again our our um you
know the easy answer is you go to any
Bank virtually any Bank uh in New
Hampshire has a Visa or MasterCard logo
on the window and you show up on in a
major bank with a Visa MasterCard logo
on the window hand that card to any
teller doesn't matter if you have an
account there or not they're required to
give you the full balance of that card
without any fees or any part of it so
just you know I'd like $200 off this
card there's no fees for that so that's
that's part of the agreement between the
banks and MasterCard and Visa uh very
protect detective of employees um
there's also it it's very easy to find
an in network Bank um I could show you
on my um on my smartphone I bring up my
uh payroll card app and just say where's
the nearest um ATM and it'll give me a
map within a half a mile of this office
um of I think 29 locations U within a
half mile that that where there's a a
fee free ATM so anyway there's that
that's fairly easy
um you know we're we're just looking to
um you know move as close as possible to
electronic and I I won't belabor this
too much more I think you understand
this pretty well from the discussion I
would love to entertain your your
questions and and talk about this a
further representative Bui thank you Mr
chair the hand uh you mentioned any a
bank in New Hampshire what if you're out
of state or out of the country uh can
you go and get a balance say if I'm in
Canada or Mexico or Greece or wherever
right will they also be obliged to uh do
that for free yeah I think US Banks any
any Bank in the US with a Visa
MasterCard logo on the window for all
major Banks um that's that's free of
charge even if you're out of state and
that kind of thing if you're doing an
international transaction there you're
getting into some there are may be some
fees for that for making an
international transaction so that that's
getting into kind of the banking fees
but you know you look at this um you
know what are what are people doing
today that get a papercheck they're
probably paying some fees to get that
done as
well okay follow thank you um so if if
I'm out of the country and I'm using my
debit card I don't get fees for
that if you're out of the country and
using a debit card there typically are
international transaction fees
associated with it so whether it's a
payroll card or any other debit card
there's typically International
transaction
fees okay okay that's
good repr
drag thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question did you just
clarifying did you say roughly only
three to four% of employers still pay by
pay per check um three to 4% of
employees is is an estimate so nacha has
they maintain you know they keep a
roster of what percentage of employee
workers already use direct deposit and
that's at least 93% 94% something like
that so the balance of 6% of employees
either get a paper check or they get the
debit cards today so it's some I'm
guessing um you know 2 3% of employees
get paper checks today still follow up
follow up I'm I'm curious uh one of the
things you just said in your testimon
make it easier is by not it's it's a
snowstorm whatever employee cannot go to
the bank cash their check I'm curious in
that same study that you just talked
about how many of those 3 to 4% of
employees do not have online banking
where you can take a picture of the
check in 30 seconds and it's in your
account I mean you still have to wait
for it to clear but you know they don't
actually physically have to go to the
bank you're right uh thank you that's a
good point uh and really the uh the
major issue is getting to the workplace
or somehow getting that physical check
so if you don't get a chance to get to
the workplace because you're sick that
day or that week or whatever um how do
you get that check and often times
employers will just mail them and so
that's several
days yeah and you know to the point
earlier of you know would be be willing
to um to pay people earlier who accepted
a a a payroll check or a payroll card U
that naturally happens um just because
um the banking system the banks
generally release payroll payments a day
or two prior to the scheduled release
date as a a marketing incentive sort of
thing so if you're you'll see
advertisements from Banks all the time
come to us you'll get your payroll two
days faster and that they actually do
that so if you get a payroll card you're
actually getting your pay on Wednesday
that everybody else is getting paid on
Friday one more question
follow so to eliminate so the you're
saying the real problem is more so just
being able to get to the workplace on on
payday um and I can understand that but
would you agree that direct deposit
already takes care of that column itself
yes this is the supplement to direct
deposit direct deposit is a great answer
for 93% at least 93% of the workforce so
for those who don't have direct deposit
for example they don't have a bank
account and they don't want a bank
account this gives them the functional
equivalent of a bank account they can
use this card to make like online
payments you know buy things on the
internet make you know travel
Arrangements things whatever you can do
with a card that um that they previously
didn't have a bank Arrangement at all
now they have an electronic account a
card they can they're in the they're in
the internet
economy thank
you pres of
grer thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question uh is ADP likely
to either save money or make money by
not having to pay postage on checks that
they ship
out it is a cost-saving uh
measure um so yeah the cost of uh you
know printing mailing um you know we we
were anxious to get to electronic as as
fast as possible as are all the small
businesses that use our services to the
extent that we save money our clients
save money that that is a factor yes
thank you follow up
uh is if if this bill were to pass would
ADP plan to charge uh employers uh for
the uh for the additional service of
employees would ADP charge for the
service of sending checks out to
employees um I we charge employers today
to print checks already so that would be
a cost savings to the extent that they
no longer have to have us Che print
physical checks for employees so it's
cheaper for them to to administer
payroll if they can do it electronically
I don't know if that answers your
you I'll give you a second
representative C thank you Mr chair then
then clar if uh thank you for taking my
question if I was to receive uh my
payroll with a wisely ATM card and I was
to go shopping with that and that's how
I chose to spend my money is ADP reive
receiv receiving um Merchant fees or any
fees for the use of my card at any of
these
Merchants um yeah my understanding is
that ADP receives a percentage of the
swipe fees the transaction fees that the
merchants pay for this so that's part of
how this is all paid for and again that
results in lower fees for the small
business clients that have to administer
payroll it does reduce their
costs representative Clark followed by
Mackenzie thank you um
you're saying that having that ad ADP
card you wouldn't necessarily have to
have a bank account correct correct and
just that was just a pre if I may um my
debit card was recently hacked and I got
it wasn't a ton of money it was like 70
bucks what happens in that case my my
bank protected me and refunded me the
money what happens if that would happen
with the ADP card I'm sorry to hear that
uh on your behalf but um yeah it's a
very good point actually the all these
debit cards are protected by um the same
rules that apply to credit cards so the
fraud protections the the protections
against unauthorized use are there with
these payroll cards so that's part of
you know Federal Law requires it and
employees can you know if they are
hacked if they are stol money stolen
from their card uh unauthorized use
anything like that uh there's even
dispute resolution so if they buy buy
something on the Internet that never
arrives they can use that to go back to
the bank and say look I never got this
you know reverse the transaction those
kinds of protections apply automatically
to employees and doesn't cost
anything just a quick followup how about
the fees that may be applied to a
bounced payment for
something um yeah for in insufficient
funds fees there there are none with um
payroll cards um basically anything that
would cause an insufficient funds
transaction uh they were just rejected
right so there's a decline transaction
that would occur if you if you buy
something there's not enough money on
your card it would just say oh you know
U purchase declined
and there's no NSF so there's no NSF
fees with these cards there may be a
declined transaction fee which is like a
think but even then I think the cfpb is
is proposing that they may prohibit that
so that's just been
announced representative McKenzie
followed
byair kill and then we'll go over
here thank you for coming for the
committee and for taking my question the
the question I have relates to the
Integrity of the
process right now if I would if a vendor
would to give me a check I could call
the bank and say is this check
good so I can verify right off the bat
there's money in the bank you isue me a
payroll card or the group of us payroll
cards how do I verify whether or not
there's money in the bank and can can
somebody uh with draw
money the person who's backing that card
are they able to withdraw money from
that account once it's in
there you understand my understand my
question yeah I'm not sure um if I got
the question right but um basically um
you know if you have a card you know
even if you don't see anybody from work
you don't get your your statement of
deductions you don't get your pay
statement that week because you're
you're off and on vacation um the
question is how much is on my card you
can just you know open up your phone
open up the app the my wisely app in the
case of ADP and it'll show you the the
balance on the card your most recent
transactions things like that so once it
follow up yes so I I'm not sure he was
done answering but were you done
answering or you going to answer the
second part or you're okay with um I
think get I don't think I wasn't sure
the nature of the question is how to
withdraw funds from it the question is
can the employer
employer take the money out employer put
money in the bank yeah to cover these
cards yeah it's it's the same as um it's
the same as any other banking
Arrangement once the employer pushes
payroll dollars to the account it's the
employes account the employer has no
visibility of what the employee does
with those monies they can't draw those
monies back out from the account I mean
the the wage and nrow laws prohibit that
anyway but the technical you know notcha
rules also prohibit um uh employers from
doing that unless they do a replacement
right away kind of thing so there are
stringent rules for how that gets done
and only in the case of like
administrative
errors I'd like to follow after with the
do gu my question please you'd like to
follow up the do yes okay so she still
here isn't
she okay not now winess all right I lost
my turn of thought kahill
go the
trio thank you Mr chair thank you Mr
Iceberg so I get my pay earlier if I had
the payroll card say I get my pay on
Wednesday am I going to be expected to
pick up lunch for Mr infant timee on
course thank you Mr chair
um are you willing to share with this
committee right now how much ADP is um
making in Revenue off of the cards that
you're currently is
issuing and or are you willing to share
with us how much ADP stands to gain by
transitioning more employees to an ADP
card based off of what you predict the
transaction swipe fees to to be that
you'll be able to
collect I I'd be happy to share that
with the committee I don't know the
answers to those questions so I'm glad
to go back and uh and find out the
answers and and convey that in a
subsequent followup if that's right
thank you you're a publicly traded
company correct
I'm sorry ADP is a publicly traded
company yes so that information is all
public not information correct yes okay
you're all set representative CES
thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking another question I maybe I'm not
envisioning this right but as a business
owner myself I'm envisioning a box of
empty debit cards sitting on my desk
that I will give out to new employees or
um Etc H how much do those debit cards
cost me
cost the employer yes to yeah because
I'm going to need if I have to replace
one on a weekend coming back for the
24hour rule I'm GNA have to obviously
print up a new one or activate a new one
how how much do those how much do those
cost it's a good question I'm not sure I
know the answer again let me take that
back and confirm it but I I do want to
say because it came up before um you
know how exactly what's the expectation
for employers if an employee loses their
card or their dog eats the card and they
need a new one um so they call the
employer and within 24 hours the
employeer is supposed to respond the way
we handle that is we give every one of
our clients a stock of you know maybe a
dozen um instant issue cards which they
can you know just feed into their
computer um and and shift the money from
the now destroyed card or lost card onto
the new card and just hand it to the
employee so it's very easy to do um in
you know and that was relates to the
question that came up earlier that you
know hey adp's closed on the weekend
what's an employer supposed to do with
this 24-hour turnaround sort of thing
but they have a stock of instant issue
cards they can use to to replace those
what those cost though I am not sure and
I don't know if there's even a separate
charge to our clients for that but let
me find out and get back to you that's
right okay um I have another question
second I'm
curious if there's
a if there's a default on the card
that's not the employer's fault it's a
Manufacturing default on a card provided
by ADP why is the employer the one
that's unnecessarily burdened on the
weekend why is that not something that's
handled by ADP it's not the employer's
fault okay I'm not sure that I got the
question if there's a problem with the
card that it's not the employer's fault
well it's the line I read earlier
1819 yes it it says uh technical
or uh a technical or a processing defect
now to me that means maybe the magnetic
strip is just defective or something
there's a bank error anything like that
that so that's not really the employer's
fault that's really something this
provided by ADP so why is it the
employer's responsibility to be back on
a weekend to pay that's a very good
question and really it should be the
responsibility of the bank or whoever
the you know whoever caused the problem
ADP if they cause the problem um the
only way that we can write that into
state law though is to to make the
employer responsible they you know they
remain responsible um but they go after
ADP they go after the bank you know uh
for reimbursement if there is a cost
that they occurred because of that under
contract we um you know we we won't
cause a problem that costs our clients
money and then leave it to them to to
pay the the difference they come to us
and say this cost me quite a bit um you
know make it good but they really just
recover that in uh via
contract if that makes
sense yeah it does make sense I'm just I
use this example last year that you know
if I'm away on the weekend four hours
away well now I'm coming back I'm
probably out that hotel room I paid for
that night but ADP is going to cover
that
expense it's a good point I'm sure
there's an infinite uh number of you
know scenarios that uh you'd want to
think about and you know does a client
make an issue of it do they come to us
and say this was very hard for me you
know what are you going to do to make it
right and you know obviously there's
many other payroll companies out there
and how are they going to behave but uh
I think that you know for for state law
purposes what you do is make the
employer the responsible party and they
sort it out with the banks they sort it
out with the payroll companies if there
are any problems okay thank you
representative
Granger thank you thank you for taking
my question so considering ADP is so
large of a company uh wouldn't they
yield If This Were passed wouldn't they
yield a massive amount of power over the
banking sector by being able to pick
winners and losers based on who they
send money for the payroll cards to so
there's a bank that has to administer
the payroll card right so wouldn't ADP
be able to pick winners and losers on
the banking Market based on who they
choose and who they choose not to do
banking
through um it's an interesting point I
mean ADP is one of many many uh payroll
companies out there we have a you know
an arrangement with a company called ly
and they have their partnership with
banks that that administer that
particular card but you know it's a it's
a free market um there are many
Arrangements many banks many payroll
companies it's a good question I'm not
really sure how to respond to it though
thank
you representative Clair followed by
representative balani um thank you both
just kind of following up on something R
Drago said and it's been actually
brought up a few times replacing a card
not every transaction shows up
immediately so say as one of the
business owners suggested they had to
replace a card and they replaced it with
say a $500 balance but the person had
used $150 of it and hadn't shown up yet
what happens to the money that they
replaced on the card not knowing that
150 or whatever has already been used
what'll happen
then it's a good question um yeah there
may be um sort of what they call um
offline transactions where for example
the phone lines are down the electricity
is off and they write down the the card
numbers and they process them later I
mean that's about the only example where
you might have a transaction that's not
instantly known to the banking system
otherwise um all of these transactions
are uh real time so they update the
banking system immediately um in every
case so that somebody can't take a card
with a certain amount of money and run
around to five different shops and spend
five times the amount that is on the
card so all that all that is very real
time but you know you could imagine if
the power's out and the phone lines are
down and somebody writes down the the
debit card numbers and transacts it
later that could happen can I follow up
please yeah that's I don't I guess that
could happen but I you know I've made
transactions on my debit cards and maybe
not see it until the next business day
okay so that's not the same scenario as
what you're saying but it does happen
well I think they issue is that the the
banking system displays the transaction
on the following day to the consumer the
banking system itself knows of the
transaction immediately and they
wouldn't permit a second over you know
additional transaction if it would
overdraw the
account okay does that but that does
that protect them as well like the
business owner as well saying okay yes
there were transactions I don't see them
yet but the bank is telling me that
there's a Balan is on the card right and
it should be the correct balance yes it
thank you Mr
chairman uh does a an employee receive a
new um pay card every single week or is
the money put do they have one pay card
and the money just keeps getting added
onto that throughout their employment
yeah it's it's one card it's
personalized um so I have mine right
here I'll show you that's okay just a
regular wisely ADP card but yeah it's
they keep the same card it just gets
reloaded follow
up so then that does beg the question as
far as the balance so if they if it's
lost stolen the swipe card uh the reader
doesn't um read or the the strip doesn't
read anymore then the whole balance is
gone not necessarily just one week's pay
so they could be leaving they could be
accumulating their balance week after
week they could yes and if you're
replacing a card that that full balance
automatically transfers to the new card
so no money is ever lost with these
cards if that's but you know if they
don't spend it then obviously it'll
you thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking the question I'm just curious if
somebody that doesn't have a bank
account is there am I correct in
thinking that there'd be no limits on
maximum that they could put on the card
could somebody just keep their whole
life savings on these cards and just
continue growing the amount on there and
would it be a limit as far as I know
there's no limit
that thank you for taking my
question um replic will clerk brought up
a good point and I just want to clarify
this so uh the money so if I if I'm
paying an employee I I put the money in
a separate account it's probably not the
right way to think of it but and then he
they get the card and they just get to
draw off the account for whatever the
actual payroll
was if a card gets lost and I have to
replace it like he brought up but I'm
not allowed to see the
transactions from the employee how do I
know how much money I actually owe the
employee with what's left on the card um
the employee is really not involved in
that sort of transaction basically the
employee comes to them and says there's
a problem I just can't use the card for
whatever reason the employer's response
is here let me give you a new card
instant issue it has the full balance of
whatever was on your previous card there
you go but they don't need to know the
details of you know the account balance
or anything like that they just the the
replacement process automatically
transfers the entire balance of the old
card onto the new
card okay so this it's probably just
because I'm used to the old school
payroll so it's not it's not one bank
account that all the employees draw draw
off of in theory it's a separate bank
account for each individual employee yes
yeah these accounts are are you know
their FDIC insured up to the $250,000
limit at the card holder level so each
card holder has the FDIC insured account
that's theirs it's a separate
account okay sorry follow up so when I
so if you issue a new card you're just
you're not actually putting any you're
not reloading the card or anything like
that you're just actually just
activating a new card and handing it to
you they slide put the number in and
then you tell you want
the so sorry and then if I lose mine and
I ask you for a new car you can usually
swipe it into something in your computer
and you give it a new name and the
person gets the card and the bank
automat atically takes whatever money is
left on that pay card that was destroyed
and puts it to the new card now
obviously there's some security codes
and everything that has to be done
but um that's just the way the procedure
works I just see a lot of questions
sorry sir it's your business but I think
I know what the questions they're asking
that was very helpful thank you um
so it's one of the dispel some of those
questions about you know you have to pay
twice or
whatever Mr avalani
thank you Mr chairman and good to see
you again um could you explain to me how
I would activate a card if I don't have
access to ADP system for your wisely
card if I have a stack of cards sitting
on my desk and hand an employee to new
card how is that card activated when ADP
is
closed so if you're the employer and
you've got a stack of cards you need to
activate a card basically the software
will permit you to do that with your own
credentials you would log into the ADP
system and you know just tell it that
you need to issue a card or replace a
card and and feed the card into the
reader and or swipe it and the software
would just kind of walk you through how
that and every employee every customer
that you have that issues pay cards
every customer would be have those that
equipment available at no
cost um again I don't know if there's a
specific cost of having a a batch of
instant issue
cards um so I I'm going to need to get
that I'm not sure if I got the question
right when I get a debit card I have to
activate it which means I have to call
into the bank activate it um I can't see
how a stack of cards on my desk handing
it to a new employee logging into your
system is going to activate that card
and sweep everything over to him without
somebody ADP pushing a button say okay
this is okay and then how do I load the
rest of his pay because he doesn't have
access to it I'm mandated in 24 hours to
pay that employee in cash or check or
anything else how how does that work for
the employer under lines 15 through
22 because it's the same we've talked
about the stb at least four times over
the last two years maybe three years
okay yeah I mean it is automated so you
don't actually have to have somebody at
ADP you don't have to talk to a person
to to do this you actually just log into
your ADP account as an employ employer
and interact with the software to tell
it what to do and it you know it can
day follow Mr chairman is there F
protection for the employer if if an
employee gets a hold of that system gets
into that system and puts a card in for
themselves and then funds it with
$10,000 and then takes off is there any
employer um that is a good question I'm
not really sure what the fraud
but yeah I'm not really sure how that
works thank you um can we talk about the
cards we can talk about the cards um the
wisely cards have a whole host of fees
associated with them um we were
discussing about Merchant fees but we're
also everybody was missing the
transaction fees this wisely charge a
transaction fee for each per each time
that that card is used at an ATM is the
person charged a transaction fee like a
$3 transaction fee for using at an
ATM um if you're using this at an ATM it
depends whether it's in network or out
of network so again um we encourage
users to go into the bank and just go to
the teller and say give me the What You
Know full balance that's always free if
you really wanted to use an ATM just you
like an ATM you want to make sure that
you're using an in network ATM and again
you pull out your phone and say you know
show me all the ATMs that are nearby
that are free and as I just did There's
you know 26 uh within a half mile here
but um there are outof network ATMs that
you know if you're just convenient
because it's you're standing next to one
and you want to use that ATM there may
be a charge uh wisely uh for instance
charges $1.75 to use an out of network
ATM but it's a kind of a convenience fee
is how we view
it uh clarification Mr chairman yes is
that the direct card or the pay card I'm
sorry I didn't quite hear is that the
direct card or the pay card because I'm
on your website looking at your fees and
it's $3 for an hour out of network
ATM um the P schedule that I have for
wisely payroll cards is $175 for out of
network ATMs so I'll I'll need to look
into that and there's also an inactivity
fee after 90 days with no transactions
yes I understand that's a that's a feed
that is charged there's no activity at
all for 90 days there's a modest fee for
that per
month and if you want to Latitude Mr
chairman if you wanted to reload um
representative Drager brought up you
wanted to reload your pay card with the
paycheck from the employer there's also
a charge of 5% of the check amount um
there's no fee for loading you know for
the employer just issuing payroll and
reloading the card every week There's no
charge to the employee for that that
there is a Reload fee if you're taking a
check from some other source like if
your friend gives you a a check or you
get a check from some you know the IRS
or something like that if you want to
take that check and convert it and put
it onto your card um you go to a
retailer and you can do that and there's
a fee for that so yes there's a fee for
cashing checks and putting them onto
your
card so I say your employer outside of
the pay card issue issues bonus checks
at the end of the year and cuts checks
out of his business yeah business
account hands it to the employee the
employee has to pay a doesn't have a
bank account has to pay that 5% of the
check amount to put it into his pay card
in order to access those funds if the
employer is issuing the payment say for
an annual bonus or something like that
typically they would just load the card
directly and there's no fee for that if
for some reason they want to hand out
paper checks and the individual wants to
take that paper check and convert it it
sounds as though there may be a fee for
that yes I can't imagine why people
would do that thank you and um again I
want to make make sure I have the right
one there's also a decline fee at an ATM
of a dollar so somebody doesn't have a
balance enough balance at an ATM they
would be charge a dollar no balance to
for that fee they would technically be
overdrawn right um yes I understand that
is a fee that we're charging for
declined transactions so somebody tries
to make a transaction there's not enough
money in the card rather than covering
the transaction and then having an in
you know an
overdraft uh condition and ansf fee
there's just a decline transaction fee
of the
dollar thank thank you and I have a few
more if that's okay pardon I have a few
more after he's done I let you want to
go thank you uh riffing off of that if I
have a total balance of
$1999 on my payroll card how would I get
that out of an ATM without incurring
such a
fee um right you'd walk into the bank
and ask for the full balance on the card
and they would hand it to you for no fee
but um you really couldn't get cents out
of of an ATM as you know so but you know
and to your point there's a lot of
sensitivity for you know what adverse
impact on employees should they be
required to pay fees you know again we
would love to work with this committee
to get this bill to where it wouldn't be
um of concern that there's these
sensitivities would be addressed you
could do it in certain ways like you
know you could make it effective for
people who are hired after some future
date which would make sure that you know
employers don't go to all to their
existing employees and say excuse me
we're we're switching you all to payroll
cards I mean mostly employers don't do
that they they're they're sensitive to
employees feelings and so forth they
don't do that but you know we could do
that if that would be help um we could
also make um you know payroll cards or
payroll checks an option at the request
of the employee rather than because
today in current law it's it's the
default option if you don't do anything
you don't provide your direct deposit
bank account number if you don't
authorize uh a a debit card you get a
payer check uh so you know be willing
willing to modify the bill to address
those concerns to make you know uh paper
checks available on request of the
concerns
follow so what specifically about paper
checks is it that we are bad uh what
what what's the problem with the paper
checks
specifically paper checks especially um
they're declining in volume you you
you know have a a fairly expensive
apparatus to administer papercheck
printing delivery reconciliation dealing
with lost and so and checks the fraud
and so forth so they're very costly
compared to electronic payments it's
also um
ineffective uh specifically for payment
of wages when people can't get to the
workplace to pick up their check and I'm
not quite sure why that's acceptable and
it really shouldn't be but that's those
Effectiveness so is it generally
expensive to just write a check or is it
just expensive if you're doing like a
lot of checks and mailing out a lot of
checks it's actually very expensive on a
you know per check basis if you're just
issuing a few which is what you know
most businesses if they have 100
employees and only three of them are
still getting payroll checks it's kind
of costly to deal with those few those
last
three so is that some so when I write a
check it costs almost nothing is is
there some part of law that prohibits
employers from just writing a check for
scent I'm not sure how to respond to
that um could you say that again I'm
sorry so I understand that if you're M
writing a lot of checks right like your
ADP and you have to send paychecks out
and you have to pay the postage on all
that that's really expensive but if you
just need to pay an employ employe and
you just have one employee that you need
to write a check it it can you see how
it isn't actually that expensive just to
write one check sure and this bill
wouldn't preclude employers from
offering paper checks if they wanted to
it just gives them it doesn't require
them to offer paper checks and again
we're willing to you know work with the
language to provide for paper checks for
those people who really truly for
whatever reason must have
them thank you I have two questions and
then I'm going to depart I have a
meeting at 5:00 in Manchester and the
vice chairman is going to take over
um my I have uh one issue and one
question the issue I have is really
lines 15 through 19 and I'm going to
read it here if an employee is unable to
access their wages due to technical or
processing defects the employer shall
immediately don't like words like
immediately in legislation okay because
that that means a lot of things to
different people immed immediately is
right
now or an hour or 24 hours what's
immediately provide the wages employer
their rep placement debit cards a check
or direct deposit in such a situation
the
employer shall be liable for late
payment of
wages and replacement wages provided
after the designated
payday I don't know why a fart by a
financial institution or a pay card
company or whatever becomes the
responsibility of the
employer and I don't know what the word
shall be liable for means shall be
liable for late payment of wages is that
a fine by the New Hampshire do is that
because my check to my my car payment
that is automatically taken out of my
debit card or my pay card bounced
because the there was something with it
so then I got a $25 fee so couple things
in there are really a little too loosy
Goosey here and I would really need a
definition um and and someone to amend
the bill to to find shall
immediately um and shall be liable what
what we're asking the employers to be
liable employers to be liable
for thank you understood
secondly um ADP is the majority
shareholder in Waverly
correct with wisely wisely
sorry um I don't know the answer to that
actually it
is thank you U um I'm sorry folks
um um before you go since we've heard
this bill before and we're more than an
hour into
it
um I'm I'm just wondering why we still
have so many questions when it really is
the same conversation the same questions
the same details um I I don't know how
to make that into a motion but I feel
like we're kind of beating a dead horse
here I appreciate your
comments hure way we will hear the same
way we're going to hear another 30
people comment opine on right to work we
allow people we allow people to do that
here and um this gentleman has come a
long way and is taken a lot of questions
I think um there's probably about 10
more minutes left um I think I just made
it longer it's okay no worries I I
respect your du do that I'm going to I'm
going to politely ask that the indulge
of the committee for another 10 or so
minutes uh make your uh questions um if
that haven't already been asked uh you
can also speak to the gentleman or
anyone else after the hearing but uh for
let the vice chairman get through uh the
last few questions I think
representative alalani has I think we'll
wrap that
up right all right have a good night
thank you thank you Mr
CH up thank you Mr chairman um so and
under page two line three why are we
exempting um organized labor groups from
this
process um I believe that was a request
that was made so we're trying to be
sensitive to um folks that have raised
concerns and um it was suggested that
organized labor shouldn't be um included
in this bill they should be able to
continue to negotiate their own terms
and
conditions follow up follow up so we're
exempting one section of um employees
but we're forcing this on every private
employer basically is what I I just
heard um it relieves employers of um the
particular responsibility of of having
to issue paper pay payroll checks if
they don't want to they they're clearly
able to continue issuing paper checks if
they prefer but it hopefully should make
lives easier for the small businesses in
in the
state follow follow as a small business
owner who reads this bill it does
not and I've used a company in the
past um as I read this bill this
is adding responsibilities to the
employer that do not need to be added to
the employer if they've paid their
employee on time um also exempting with
the Indulgence of the chair also
exempting other things tells me that
there is a an issue with this that we're
forcing certain segments to be you know
rolled into payroll cause but we're
exempting others so it's okay to write
paper checks for union members but not
for regular employees I'm
just we're adding something to a bill
that was brought back again so this is
obviously a change that brought this
again and from the last three times that
I've had interactions with you over this
bill we've changed nothing in section D
to alleviate the issue for the
employers okay that's a good point I
think we've been trying to be very very
careful about um not inconveniencing
employees but it did add some burden to
employers to make sure that they address
these um you know points of failure and
so forth here it's a good
point we're happy to consider changes to
this I will end there Mr chairman thank
you all right other questions
representative
kill uh actually Mr chairman my question
is for
you uh whereas this the payroll cards
are in use now and through Mr avani's
testimony and other things that we've
learned or do you think we should
perhaps change this bill so it has more
protections for the people who are being
paid with payroll cards uh since we're
learning more about the pitfalls and I'm
not sure if uh people who are paid with
payroll cards know all the
pitfalls
um as this bill has been submitted to
our committee it is now our bill and if
we have amendments to fix that we think
we can fix the issues that were brought
up here um we can work on
that or we may determine as has happened
in the past that it's it's beyond our
ability to do within the time allotted
and right we may not so that's perhaps
legislate well thank you perhaps yes are
there other questions representative
grer uh thank you so you mentioned uh
employers requesting this how many
employers are are demanding this change
and um are they able to
testify we we haven't asked um our
clients to testify on this sort of Bill
it's really not a big issue for any one
employer it's kind of a big issue for
the system overall but um if you ask any
one employer that's not a big enough
issue to take time to you know argue
that well I really shouldn't have to
issue paper payroll checks it's not that
Vantage thank
you are there other
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony thank you for
the
opportunity there was a comment earlier
representative McKenzie I I think you
okay I I most certainly
do um
but
are there before we do that are there
any other members of the audience that
wished to testify and that was so we had
one question for you but he
doesn't it
wasn't uh well it so representative
Alani you had you wanted to bring up the
if we were bringing the do up I I happy
to ask question oh it's just for you
thank you all right so give her a chance
to get settled and and we can continue
see that's why I didn't ask for the
sheets
yet hi all right so um I think this is a
new bill so my name is Tracy mcra I am
an attorney and legislative le as on for
the New Hampshire Department of Labor
and yes representative
avalani thank you Mr chairman thank you
Mr McGrath for taking the questions um
seeing as this bill has been before us
multiple times are you familiar with it
once or twice I've read it yes um the
yes follow up the chairman um infantine
had asked a couple questions and those
are the same questions as an employer I
would have shall immediately provide
wages and then shall be liable could you
explain to the committee what those what
what the do would it constru that as an
employee being late with wages and with
the law that is written now under
275 so the current law basically puts
the employer at as the person or entity
primarily responsible for payment of
wages they can hire other companies to
pay the wages for them but the employer
remains primarily responsible so in this
particular case if the employer does not
comply with current New Hampshire law in
payment of these wages on time they can
be held liable for late payment meaning
that there would be potential civil
penalties but payment would have to be
issued there would likely be a hearing
and then it would be up to uh a hearing
officer to make any final designations
and
determinations follow um if it was found
to be that it was outside of the
employers doing technical issue on the
issuing card company uh banking error
something like that
um with the do under how this bill is
written go after the company that made
the mistake no thank you thank you
chairman thank you um now that she's up
question
than so the question I I had asked
earlier um relates to the money in the
bank at the time the payroll is executed
my concern is
and that an employer could issue the
checks or issue pay cards or issue some
other vehicle for payment and what
happens if they yank that money out
before the before the any of this thing
happens well I think that that's an
issue that could theoretically happen in
the current process of things um however
there are ways for the employee to come
to the Department of Labor and say that
they're not being paid their wages by
going through a wage
claim uh there's also the opportunity to
go to Superior Court for different kinds
of Equitable relief cool thank
you are there any other questions for
the
Department seeing none thank you very
much for uh answering our
questions and before I close this um we
had one sign in on the blue sheet in
favor of the bill and if I can now I
forgot the
number have I got 164 48 I was just
going to bring up the
current um
online because uh will has has the uh
the paper sheet and this is the pink
card for the last and online we had four
people sign in support and 30 people in
opposition and that is the current
number that's available on our our
legislative portal so with that I will
close the hearing on House Bill 1648 and
that concludes our business for today so
everyone